So, ich bin noch ein bisschen früher, weil was soll ich hier sinnlos vom Rechner setzen?
Einfach noch 10 Minuten, bloß das 9 ist oder so, das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Und ihr habt ja halbwegs gut geschlafen, ja.
Mir ging es so, die Katze war 2-3 mal, 2 mal, 2 mal, heute Nacht an der Tür und ging mir
auf den Keks, da muss man dann das übliche machen, wenn die Katze an der Tür kratzt,
muss ich die Tür aufmachen und muss mit der Katze ins Bad gehen und ihr den Wasserhahn
anmachen, weil dann dringt die Wasser aus dem Wasserhahn, das geht, das ist ganz wichtig,
das Wasser aus dem Katzenbrunnen ist nachts nicht gut genug, das muss aus dem Wasserhahn
kommen.
Ja, nachher müssen wir noch die GitHub Actions weitermachen, aber ohne Qemo, das gebe ich
mir nicht nochmal, meine liegt sogar manchmal im Waschbecken drin und wartet, bis ich rüber
ins Bad komme und wenn ich dann den Wasserhahn im Waschbecken anmache, dann bleibt die Katze
liegen und lässt sich voll sprühen davon, bis sie dann irgendwann denkt, ah ok, jetzt
werde ich zu nass, jetzt muss ich aufstehen, small access point, moin, ohbei, hast dich
ja renehmt, du bist jetzt das small access point, der Boss ist auch am Start, Massive,
was empfiehlt uns, hat YouTube noch irgendwelche nice Empfehlungen, zeig mal her, hacking Google,
das ist ein Google Werbevideo, die Videos sind ja mal wieder absolut, ich will sie alle
sehen, lul, Hardline hat better destruction than Battlefield 20, ja das wundert mich nicht,
YouTube versucht mir immer irgendwelche Fußballvideos unterzuschieben, ich glaube ich hab noch nicht
einmal ein Fußballvideo auf YouTube geguckt, das ist wieder nichts gescheites bei, weird
computers, ok, das könnte tatsächlich, von denen gucke ich immer ganz gern, ich muss
mal immer im Handy gucken, ja jetzt schon, ihr wisst doch immer wenn ich den Stream anmache
und der cute Chat am Start ist, gehts mir gut, ich muss mal im Handy gucken, hab ich
auch irgendwelche Videos gespeichert, wo ich denke, hey das muss ich unbedingt mit euch
angucken, aber ich glaube ich hab ja extra eine Playlist gemacht, wenn ich da irgendwelche
Sachen sehe für Sonntag, wo ich mir immer denke, ah das könnte man uns angucken, dann
speichere ich das, meine Playlist ist, nee hier, used edit, nope da ist nichts dabei,
watch later, auch nichts dabei, ja dann, dann wars das wohl, kennst du Tools für das Projektmanagement
oder für Notizen empfehlen, also für das Projektmanagement keine Ahnung, für Notizen
wenn man kein Problem mit Closed Source hat, ist das hier tatsächlich nicht verkehrt,
ich mag, ich mag ja das hier ganz, ganz gern, vor allem weil es native notifications integrated
von der jeweiligen Plattform, war auch wieder geil, man hat es aber glaube ich verstanden,
also ist integrated native notifications von der Plattform, der fat dude ist auch am Start,
ex, exellent, dazu kann ich nur sagen, oder so, ja das ist tatsächlich ganz gut, oin
achts, oh guck mal, nightbot ist auch schon da, so, war die Woche irgendwas spannendes
was ich verpasst habe, gab es irgendwas, zeige ich mal ganz schnell hier, irgendwas was trenntet,
wir machen mal ganz schnell, schnell durch, mal kurz gucken ob der Kerl geantwortet hat
auf das issue, nope, dann mache ich es heute zu, sowas trenntet, aber wo ist das, ja, mach
noch mehr Tabs auf, habe ich, habe ich, habe ich, ich habe auch hier in der vm noch extra
welche auf, also was trenntet denn heute, nein, also was trenntet, ähm, Low-Code-Framework-Kackel,
Alter das, egal, äh, AI-Image-Zeug, es trenntet ein C++-Repo, ok, es gibt Sachen die, die
gibt es zwar, aber die muss ich mir nicht angucken, noch mehr, noch mehr Docs, oh, mich nicht,
keine Ahnung, React, auch, egal, ok, irgendwas, config-ding, stonks Zeug, Neo-Wim, Rust, was
sonst, Blazingly-Fast, stonks, ok, nichts dabei was mich groß interessiert, alles klar, so,
sonst, ist sonst diese Woche irgendwas spannendes passiert, Fachkräftemangel, weniger Blabla,
mehr Kohle, ha, ja, das denke ich mir auch immer, ich mein Blabla muss nicht über zwangsläufig
in dem Fall was schlechtes sein, ja, aber mehr Kohle ist immer gut, ist halt so, muss
ich nicht, müssen sich alle nicht wundern, wenn sie den Leuten nichts ordentliches bezahlen
wollen, dann gibt es halt auch nicht wirklich gute Leute, äh, gute Leute können sich das
aktuell aussuchen und die gehen bestimmt nicht irgendwo hin, weil es da ein Obstkorb
einmal die Woche umsonst gibt und sonst nix. Planlose Headhunter, ja, wir haben letztens
eine Bewerbung gekriegt von einem, der Lebenslauf war garantiert, bisschen laut, oder, der Lebenslauf
war garantiert, äh, auch, also richtig frisiert von irgendeinem Vermittlungsunternehmen oder
von irgendeinem Headhunter, irgendeiner Agentur oder was, wie sich das auch genau nennt, und
der konnte wirklich alles, von Solaris bis BSD, alle Linux-Distributionen, VMWare, der
hatte wirklich acht Seiten Lebenslauf, der war richtig krass, der Typ, also zumindest
hat er das laut seinem Headhunter. Ich persönlich bin ja bei sowas immer skeptisch, ich denke
mir, alter, wenn der quasi einmal querbeht, quasi von Linux, Windows, VMWare, Cloud und
wahrscheinlich alle Programmiersprachen, äh, Embedded-Entwicklung und sonst sowas,
also wenn der quasi alles kann, was es in der IT so gibt, dann kann er wahrscheinlich
nix richtig. Weil anders geht das nicht. Selbst wenn du, äh, ein Jahr vor Rente bist
und quasi dein ganzes Leben lang nur was gelernt hast, du kannst gar nicht alles können. Und
du musst auch gar nicht alles können. So ein bisschen Ahnung von manchen Gebieten ist
teilweise viel besser, als wirklich alles zu können. Das geht überhaupt nicht. Aber
ganz davon abgesehen, ich finde es ja gut, wenn man eine Übersicht hat, aber Übersicht
in ein paar Gebieten, ja, das reicht ja. Du musst ja nicht zwei, drei, vier, fünf komplett
unterschiedliche Bereiche haben, wo du angeblich der Ultra-Pro bist, was die alle nicht sind.
Generell, es kam selten vor, dass irgendwelche vermittelten Consultants und externe Experten
und sonst was diese bei uns eingestellt haben, dass ich wirklich gedacht habe, ey, alter,
der hat mega Plan. Also es kommt tatsächlich selten vor. Letztens hat mich tatsächlich
mal wieder einer überrascht, der hat mir irgendein System-D, System-CTL-Parameter gezeigt
bzw. erzählt, den ich noch nicht kannte. Und ihr könnt von ausgehen, dass es im Linux-Bereich
relativ wenig gibt, was ich da so von irgendwelchen Consultants noch spannendes Neues erzählt
gekriege. Ich mache den Kram einfach zu lang für. Das heißt nicht, dass ich alles weiß,
ganz im Gegenteil, ich weiß genug, dass ich weiß, dass ich von ganz vielen Bereichen keine
Ahnung habe, aber es gibt wenig Leute, die dir da tiefgreifende neue Sachen erzählen
können, weil die haben auch keine Ahnung. Das kommt wirklich selten vor. Deswegen war
ich da positiv überrascht, dass mir letztens einer was Neues über System-D bzw. eigentlich
weiß ich nur ein Parameter gezeigt hat, mit dem man Services nicht nur disablen kann,
sondern Services komplett am Starten hindern kann. Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das gibt.
Einmal lesen reicht ja nicht. Du liest ja kein Pysen-Buch und kannst es danach. Du hast vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr Plan, was du gucken musst, wenn was nicht geht. Genau, das kannte ich
nicht. Mask und unmask. Das kannte ich nicht. Das hat er letztens erzählt, so nachdem, ob
er das nicht damit und damit macht. Keine Ahnung, habe ich hier nie was von gehört.
Also ach guck mal da. Wusste ich nicht, dass das gibt. Enable, disable kannte ich, aber
das bezieht sich ja immer nur auf System-Start. Ob man Booten starten soll oder nicht. Aber
ich glaube System-D und ich werden eh keine dicken Freunde mehr. Die Zeit ist vorbei.
Hat nicht funktioniert. Ey stimmt. Warum ich die Ss rauskopiere, nicht. Ich kopiere alles
mögliche raus. Auch die Einsen und Zeug. Da haben wir doch schon den Clip dazu. Ja leider
gibt es das meistens nicht. Die meisten haben keinen Plan, was sie machen. Wo ich mich halt
immer frage, wenn du dir irgendwelche Consultants kaufst, hört sich das ja vom Wort so an, als
holst du die dir, weil du die konsultieren musst, weil du die fragen musst zu was, wo
du selbst keine Ahnung von hast. Und es kam ganz selten vor, dass ich mal irgendeinen Konsulten
erlebt habe, wo ich überhaupt gewusst hätte, zu was ich den eigentlich konsultieren will.
Die meisten sind wirklich planlos. Wir hatten mal einen, der hat beispielsweise einen Monat
bei uns gesessen und hat die ganze Zeit nichts mehr, also nicht mehr geschafft als sein
Notebook einzurichten. Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, was ist mit dem los. Da hatten wir
einen anderen, der hat nach eineinhalb Wochen das Storage System kaputt gemacht. Das habe
ich euch ja schon erzählt. Oder am zweiten Tag oder so das Storage System kaputt gemacht.
Dann hatten wir welche, die irgendwie auch nach zwei, drei Wochen festgestellt haben,
Alter, was die hier von mir wollen, habe ich keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich auch, weil
sie so einen super frisierten Lebenslauf hatten. Am geilsten war immer noch der Typ, der war
eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, aber die hatten bei uns mal einen eingekauft, weil sie sich
ernsthaft gedacht haben, sie wollen ZFS machen. Damals hieß ZFS, man möchte das auf Solaris
machen. Und die haben wirklich einen eingekauft, der sich auskennt mit Solaris und ZFS und
als der dann da war, haben sie gesagt, nope, wir machen doch kein Solaris und ZFS und dann
sollte der irgendwelche Linux Config Management Sachen machen, auf die er keinen Bock hatte
und dementsprechend in die Hose ist das auch gegangen. Der war dann auch nach einem halben
Jahr wieder weg, aber den habe ich mir insofern gemerkt, der hatte ein bisschen einen Dachschaden,
das habe ich auch schon erzählt. Der hatte seinen Desktop so eingestellt, dass wenn er
mit der, ist kein Witz jetzt Leute, wenn er mit dem Mauszeiger an den Bildschirmrand
gekommen ist, dann hat sein PC Speaker gesummt. Also der Typ saß vom Rechner und hat's Mauszeiger
an den Bildschirmrand bewegt und dann hat er PC Speaker gemacht und dann hat er nicht
irgendwie gesagt, was war denn das, sondern hat's immer auf sein Desktop geschoben, hat
immer gesagt, der scheiß Gnome. Wisst ihr, als gäbe es in Gnome einen Setting, richtig,
als gäbe es in Gnome einen Setting, dass den PC Speaker summen lässt, wenn du mit dem Mauszeiger
an den Bildschirmrand kommst. Genau der Typ. Ja beides, beides. Erstens die Leute, die
sie beauftragen, wissen wahrscheinlich nicht so genau, was sie sich da einkaufen, aber wenn
die was in ihrem Lebenslauf stehen haben und am Endeffekt dann keine Ahnung davon haben,
wenn da irgendwelche angeblichen Linux und High Availability Experten sind, laut Lebenslauf,
die da aber keinen Plan davon haben, dann ist es Schuld des Consultants, wobei man halt
sagen muss, es ist eher Schuld des Vermittlers, weil der Lebenslauf wahrscheinlich so krass
frisiert ist, dass du nichts mehr vom ursprünglichen Lebenslauf erkennst, aber im Endeffekt ist
es natürlich Schuld des Consultants, ich meine du willst den kaufen für ein spezielles
Thema und im Detail stellst du dann fest, er kann das gar nicht. Das merkst du bei
denen ja auch schlecht am Anfang, weil eins, können alle Consulten wahnsinnig gut kurzzeitig
Ahnung vermitteln, das ist ja auch ihr hauptsächlicher Job. Hast du schon gewechselt? Ne, ich hab
letzte Woche tatsächlich mit meinem Chef am Freitag noch mal gemietet und es hat sich
alles irgendwie so ein bisschen wieder beruhigt, auch was die Home Office Thematik angeht.
Ja, mal gucken. Aber wie gesagt, also ich gucke weiter, wenn ich was finde, was Remote
ist oder sagen wir mal höchstens einen Tag die Woche hin, wenn es was in der Nähe ist,
100% Remote wäre mir am liebsten, weil dann kann das auch eine Firma sein, die in München
oder so ist. Also wenn ich was finde, was Remote ist und geldtechnisch das gleiche,
wenn ich sogar besser bezahlt, dann bin ich weg. Also sollte beides der Fall sein, dann
bin ich sicher weg, also natürlich muss mich der Laden ansprechen und ich muss einen guten
Eindruck von denen haben und die von mir logischerweise, aber sollte beides zusammenkommen, bisher
hatte ich nur den Fall 100% Remote, aber Geld ungefähr das gleiche, da habe ich gezögert,
da habe ich gedacht, hm, machst du nicht, hm, weiß nicht, da habe ich mir das, da habe
ich noch überlegt, sollte aber wirklich jetzt jemand um die Ecke kommen und sagen, hey Max,
100% Remote und es gibt sogar noch mehr Kohle, gar nicht mal so viel mehr, aber hofft doch
mehr, wenn es natürlich viel mehr ist, umso leichter fällt die Entscheidung, dann bin
ich wahrscheinlich weg. Wie oft bist du im Moment 1-2 mal die Woche? Nur Johnny, moin.
Ja, Bahn fahren muss man ab und zu trotzdem, Leute, ich finde es ja immer witzig auf Twitter,
wenn die Leute dann denken, Max, ich denke, du hast dir ein Auto gekauft, du fährst jetzt
nicht mehr mit der Bahn, doch, mache ich weiterhin. Vielleicht, nicht mehr, jede Strecke, überall,
aber ich meine, ich hatte ja vorher auch den Agila und trotzdem Bahn gefahren, ey, am Montag
sind die, nee, wann war das? Nee, Sekunde, die gingen mir letztens wieder so massiv auf
den Sack hier, hier, guckt sie euch an, Freitag war das, ne, siebter, die gingen mir so massiv
wieder auf den Sack, ich bin pünktlich losgefahren und wir haben es dann geschafft, eine halbe
Stunde Verspätung am Ende zu haben, das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht, was hier steht, also
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das hier geschrieben habe, waren wir angeblich schon in Frankfurt
Süd weg und in Wirklichkeit standen wir in Maincourt rum und es ging nicht weiter und
eigentlich soll dieser Zug, das ist auch so ein absolutes, komplettes Unding, was viel
zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit bekommt und zwar eigentlich soll dieser Zug fahren bis nach Rüsselsheim,
der fährt aber jedes zweite Mal nicht durch bis nach Rüsselsheim, dann denke ich mir
immer, das ist ein komplettes Versagen auf ganzer Linie, du kannst doch nicht regelmäßig
die Züge einfach nicht die Strecke fahren lassen, wofür sie sind, ich mein, ich hab
Glück, ich muss nicht nach Rüsselsheim, aber es gibt sicherlich genug Leute, die wollen
nach Rüsselsheim, das kann doch nicht sein, dass ein Zug laufen nicht da hin fährt, wo
der Lautplan hinfahren sollte, das sind solche Drecksficker, das ist der Wahnsinn, dieser ganze
Haufen aus Bahn, ich hab meinen Wackelkontakt ausgelöst an meinem Mute Knopf, Moment, jetzt
gehts wieder, weil ich auf den Tisch gehauen hab, so ist es, Mute Knopf, nicht Wut Knopf,
Mute, ich hab einen Knopf, da kann ich draufhauen bzw. draufdrücken, wenn ich Mikro und alles
muten will und nicht irgendwie erst den OBS rumklicken will, dann kann ja mal sein, dass
einer anruft oder so, Family Friendlies Team, ja sobald es in die Bahn geht, ist vorbei
mit Family Friendly, ja und der hat halt einen Wackelkontakt und wenn ich zu sehr drauf haue,
dann geht das Mikro nicht mehr, das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, das ist wirklich so ein Scheiß
vereinigbar, also dieses ganze Zusammenwirken da aus Politik, als Verantwortung in der Politik,
der Bahnvorstand, generell die Bahn, es ist eigentlich ein komplettes Anlügen der Bevölkerung
im Endeffekt bei der Bahn, auch diese ganzen Geschichten mit, wir drehen um und dann ist
das Hatterzug nicht Verspätung, wir faken schon unsere Statistiken bis zum geht nicht
mehr und halten trotzdem unsere eigenen Ziele nicht ein und immer jährlich die gleichen
Aussagen, oh ja wir verbessern uns, wir verbessern uns nächstes Jahr, OBS hat ja doch nicht
funktioniert, da müssen einfach Konsequenzen dran hängen, ihr löschen ist ja auch nicht
Sinn und Zweck der Übung, das muss funktionieren, wir sind das viertreichste Land der Welt und
wir kriegen es nicht geschissen, wahrscheinlich hat Simbabwe bessere Bahnen, die haben vielleicht
nur eine, aber die fährt dann wenigstens auch, also die haben es wirklich nicht nur
10 Jahre, die haben es die letzten 30, 40 Jahre komplett verschissen, ja ich werde mir
irgendwann Overwatch 2 auch sicherlich angucken, gerade weil es free to play ist, aber aktuell
habe ich da echt keinen, ich müsste heute eigentlich das Video zum Interz, zum Breitbandausbau
aufnehmen, aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das überhaupt hinkriege, aber das wird auf
jeden Fall das nächste Video, ich habe ja schon zweimal gesagt, das wird das nächste
Video und muss jetzt auch das nächste Video werden, also das muss ich noch machen und
ja theoretisch müsste ich mir auch mal Overwatch 2 angucken, aber gut man, wenn nicht, wenn
nicht ist es auch nicht wild, ich glaube nicht, dass ich wieder in das Overwatch Hype da
verfallen werde, das Game hat mich zu verbrannt oder zu fällig gemacht, ich habe es ja auch
wieder, das war das letzte Game, weil ich so richtig hardcore gegrindet habe, 24-7, auch
mit premade team und voice comms und allem, aber das kann ich nochmal, vor allem wenn
ich mich dran erinnere, wie Blizzard Overwatch 1 gehandelt hat, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass es Overwatch 2 besser wird, ich meine, sie haben eine bessere Voraussetzung, weil
es free to play ist, was Spielerbasis angeht, aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass es an den
Hype rankommt, wie vom ersten Overwatch, das war ja wirklich, das wurde ja, es gab
Overwatch TikTok Memes, das kann sich noch eigentlich an diesen blöden Song erinnern,
den sie alle nachgesungen haben, überall, I'm already Tracer und dieses Zeug, also der
Overwatch 1 Hype, der war schon echt real, als das rausgekommen ist, 5 ist auch mehr
Geschwitze, ach wahrscheinlich ist es das gleiche Geschwitze, das finde ich in Overwatch
nicht schlimm, in ranked ist das vollkommen in Ordnung, ranked muss der Inbegriff von
Geschwitze sein, die haben aber, zum Glück ist 2CP glaube ich raus mittlerweile, das
war ja das schlimmste überhaupt, alter 2CP, wenn ich das, wenn ich das, wenn ich daran
schon denke, kriege ich Ausschläge, so genug geflamed, genug über Overwatch und die Bahn
hergezogen, hat Youtube nicht irgendwas erheiterndes, was man sich jetzt angucken kann, OW1 Reskin,
ja vielleicht kann ich nichts zu sagen, aber es ist halt F2P, was auf jeden Fall für die
Playerbase potentiell besser sein sollte. Google vs DuckDuckGo, welche Suchmaschine
ist die beste? Includes Paid Promotion, lass mich raten NordVPN oder? Da werden überhaupt
Besuchergebnisse getestet, äh geil. Exposed, das, die Überschriften von eben immer.
Irgendwie ist nichts spannendes dabei, was man sich angucken kann, was sagt, was macht
eigentlich Levelcap? Levelcap, Chebatet er uns, nein nicht Luxus, was? Luxus Gaming,
ne nicht Linux, Luxus Gaming Alter, Linux Gaming ist alles andere als Luxus Gaming,
ne er reacted live, er hat kein, ja gut. Ich glaube das haben wir schon geguckt, das ist
nicht das mit dem roten Marker oder? Das war ein anderes Video mit diesem, mit diesem,
was war das nochmal für ein Video? In dieser Marketing Agentur, wir wollen zwei parallele
rote Linien, die nicht parallel sind oder irgendwie sowas und dann, warum geht das nicht,
warum sagen sie gleich, dass das nicht geht? Das haben wir uns gestern schon was zu durchgelesen.
Ne, muss ich erstmal Overwatch spielen. So, was können wir uns jetzt angucken? Komplizierte
Zollermeldungen. So viel verdient man als Einsteiger im Onlinehandel. Also ich kann
euch sagen, wie viel man bei AliExpress verdient, wahrscheinlich gar nichts. Wahrscheinlich
kriegst du als einziges, wenn du bei AliExpress bei irgendeinem komischen China-Chinesen-Job
arbeitest, du kriegst irgendwo einen Käfig mit einem Dach drüber. Das reicht als Bezahlung.
Wobei ich letztens in Artikel gelesen habe, stellt euch vor, stellt euch vor, die China-Chinesen,
die möchten mittlerweile auch nicht mehr alle Jobs machen, weil sie insgesamt quasi schon
ein Entwicklungsniveau oder Wohlstandsniveau erreicht haben, dass die meisten Chinesen
es nicht mehr nötig haben, den letzten Track zu machen. Finde ich ja an sich eigentlich
gut. So, und wisst ihr was jetzt passiert? Ich hab letztens was drüber gelesen. Wisst
ihr was jetzt passiert? Also, wenn die China-Chinesen schon die absolut unmenschlichen Jobs nicht
mehr machen wollen, die es da gibt, was machen sie jetzt? Ja klar, das wird an der Grenze
zu Nordkorea gemacht und die fahren einmal am Tag Nordkoreaner rüber nach China, lassen
den den unmenschlichen Dreck machen und bezahlen sie nicht richtig, weil sie selbst keinen
Bock mal drauf haben. Also es gibt anscheinend immer noch, es gibt anscheinend immer noch,
du kannst immer weiter die Leiter runter, ja. Früher haben sie bei uns den Kram nach China
oder sonst wo ausgesourct, haben sich gesagt, ach was jucken uns Arbeitsbedingungen, Menschenrechte
und sonst was und jetzt denken sich die Chinesen das auch, wie, unsere Leute wollen das nicht
mal machen, ah die Nordkoreaner, die machen das schon. Ja, letztens hast du was drüber
gelesen, das heißt, ja sogar in China sind sie sich teilweise jetzt zu, ja zu advanced
um den ganzen Crap zu machen, das ist doch auch Gutes. Was angeblich für Kopfhörer,
was denn? Ladekabel? Ja, das, das, das, da gab's doch, gab's doch grad, gab's doch hier
sogar ein Video irgendwie zu. Oh guck mal, ich krieg mein Fachkräftemangel Video empfohlen.
Ja, Klinkenbuxten werden wir nicht mal sehen. Die können ihr auch schlecht einem Hersteller
vorschreiben, ihr müsst das da dran machen. Ich gehe mal davon aus, das einzige was sie
machen können ist dem Hersteller, wenn es halt einen Ladeanschluss gibt, ihm vorzuschreiben,
es muss USB-C sein. Joa, ich bin mal gespannt, ob Apple dann auch USB-C bei allen Geräten
macht. Da ist ja teilweise immer noch Lightning angesagt, ich glaube die ganz, haben nicht
die ganz neuen iPhones schon USB-C? Oder sind die auch noch Lightning, nicht Lightning,
was erzähl ich denn? Doch, Lightning. Hältst du was von Intel GPUs? Nö, aktuell nicht,
gibt's ja nix, was du als Gamer brauchen kannst. Nur die größeren iPads haben USB-C, ja,
kann schon sein, dass sie das hinkriegen. Ich mein, es dürfte jetzt kein großes Ding
sein. Einmal abwarten, mal abwarten, da gibt's bestimmt wieder irgendwelche Hintertürchen
und Absprachen mit irgendwelchen Herstellern. Das wäre doch gelacht, wenn das auch einfach
so eins zu eins kommt und dann alles auf einmal USB-C hat. Da bin ich mal gespannt, wir werden
es erleben. Wahrscheinlich wird das verschoben. Das ist wahrscheinlich genauso sicher mit
2024, wie dass wir die Zeitumstellung abgeschafft haben vor drei Jahren, wo alle dafür gestimmt
haben, die abgestimmt haben. Die Zeitumstellung ist bis heute noch da. Dann haben wir Pech,
weil bis irgendwelche Sachen geabdechert werden bei uns, das dauert wahrscheinlich
dann 15 Jahre wieder. Aber es wird in nächster Zeit nichts besseres in dem Sinn rauskommen
wie USB-C. Mein, USB-C hat sicherlich vielleicht die ein oder anderen Probleme, aber der Stecker
ist tatsächlich mal was sinnvolles. Als erstes was, worauf sich zum größten Teil die Hersteller
der gesamten Welt irgendwie drauf jetzt eingeschossen haben. Es ist verpolungs, also du kannst links
und rechts einstecken und alles gut. Ja, irgendwie sowas, das war schon klar. Mal gucken, was
er zu sagt. Der ist bestimmt wieder am flamen. Die Videos von ihm sind eh immer, du kannst
dir die erste Minute angucken und der Rest ist eigentlich so unsinnig. Ja gut, es soll
ja auch anscheinend ums Laden gehen. Dass das Ding für Bandbreite fahren kann, ist offen
das ist ja klar, weil man weiß ja nicht, ob es USB 3.2 Gen 3.1 2x5 ist oder Gen 4.0
Gen 1x2 oder gar 40G x 5.78, das weiß man nicht. Der Stecker ist der Stecker und was
dann dann drüber gemacht wird, ist natürlich was anderes. Kifkin, Dankeschön für die
33 Monate. Massive Subscription hier. Extrem nice. Können wir uns mal angucken. So, was
haben wir denn hier sonst noch zu bieten? Ah, weißt du was, jetzt habe ich das. Ja,
wir gucken uns das mal kurz an. So, was erzähle ich denn? Ja, okay. Charger, Charger. Also
ich denke, dass sie noch mehr haben können. Ja, ob das wirklich an diesem Stichtag sein
wird. Siehst du, ihr seid schon die ersten Ausnahms. 4090 haben gekauft. Ach, kann man
die jetzt bestellen oder was? Kann man die jetzt bestellen? Nee. Aha, ab 12.10.
Das ist schon ganz schön teuer, oder? Da sind ja die Preise zu Miningzeiten noch billig
gewesen. Das ist ganz schön teuer. Ah, so Rockstricks. Gibt es schon Tests? In Computerbase
oder so haben die irgendwelche Tests von Grafikkarten? Ich meine, ich bestelle doch keine Grafikkarte
zur Release, ohne mal irgendeinen Test drüber gelesen zu haben, wie laut die Lüfter sind
und sonst was. Ich kann das doch nicht komplett im Sack bestellen. Hat der Bauer was? Der
hat doch immer was in der Richtung, der Auer. YouTube. Bullshit-Markt, da hat er wohl recht.
Mich interessiert aber eher beispielsweise, wie laut es ist. Man weiß halt nicht, gerade
Custom Sachen, die können natürlich viel besser sein, aber muss sagen, die offiziellen
Karten waren ja schon immer ganz gut. Das ist halt viel zu teuer. Ich meine, ich kaufe
doch keine für 2500 Euro, wenn ich eine für 2000 Euro kaufen kann. Nee, ich warte mal.
Im Zweifelsfall kaufe ich das in zwei Monaten was. Ab wann gibt es denn die neuen Ryzen
zu kaufen? Ryzen 7? Gibt's die schon? AMD.com auf Verfügbarkeit prüfen. New Product. Hey,
nice. Das heißt allen Ernstes, ich könnte mir wirklich dieses Jahr einen neuen Rechner
bauen. Das Problem ist, das wird viel zu teuer. Das kostet 4500 Euro, wenn ich das wirklich
machen sollte. Wir haben es ja letztens ausgerechnet. Ist mir eigentlich nicht wert im Vergleich
zu meinem aktuellen Rechner? Mein aktueller Rechner hat einfach alles, was ich brauche.
Die B650-Boards. Wann stellt ein Intel irgendwas vor? Müsste doch auch irgendwann. Pfff, Alter,
was Preise, man. Was hat denn S-Rock? Warum ist die S-Rock-Seite eigentlich so schlecht?
AM5 brauche ich, gell? Gatschi-Buzz. Kommen wir mal kurz bei Geizhals. Was günstige Mainboards
sind. Was hat ein aktueller Rechner für Komponenten? Ich habe einen 8700K und einen 1080Ti. Das
ist zwar überhaupt nicht mehr zeitgemäß, aber immer noch ziemlich gut. Das ist auch
so was. Das hat es früher echt nicht gegeben, dass ich nach 5 Jahren einen Rechner habe
und immer noch alles Aktuellste in besten Details spielen kann. So, wir gucken mal kurz.
Was hat der Mainboard? Sockel AM5? Ja, ein Schnapper. MSI Mac Godlike. Ok, warum, warum,
warum? Was kann das so Geiles, dass es so teuer ist? Ah, das ist die mega krasseste
Spannungswandler seit dem Urknall. Was hat es denn für ein Netzwerk? Hat es denn wenigstens
ein 10G? Seht ihr irgendwie was? Habt ihr irgendwas gesehen? Was hat das für ein Netzwerk?
Ich sehe nichts. Wireless sehe ich. Ach, hier Anschlüsse intern. Ok, das ist USB. 2,5G
sogar nur. Nee, stimmt doch gar nicht. Was erzählt der denn wieder für Zeug? Der hat
eine 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte und eine 2,5 Gigabit. Aber trotzdem, es macht keinen Sinn
dafür so viel Geld auszugeben. Warum möchte MSI dafür so viel Geld haben? Das verstehe
ich nicht. Und warum? Ja, komm lass mich die Seite aufmachen. Ein Display auf dem Mainboard,
ja aber weshalb? Warum? Warum soll ich für Display auf dem Mainboard 1000 Euro bezahlen?
Das ist ein Schwachsinn. Also das muss irgendwelche anderen Vorteile haben, dass sich das besonders
gut für flüssig, Stickstoff, der Bauer-Style, über Takt-Weltrekorde eignet oder so. Alles
andere ergibt ja gar keinen Sinn. Wenn ich ein Display am Mainboard haben will, ne will
ich nicht, aber wenn ich das haben möchte aus irgendwelchen Gründen, dann hole ich
mir so einen Case für den Raspberry Pi, so einen 5-7 Zoll Case und papp den da irgendwie
ins Gehäuse rein und lass den was auslesen, wenn es unbedingt sein. Das ist Schwachsinn,
totaler Blödsinn, braucht kein Mensch. So, zeig mal her Preis. Was ist das günstigste?
209 Euro, da kommen wir der Sache doch schon näher. Ich werde mal abwarten Leute, ich
wollte eigentlich direkt zur Release zuschlagen, aber es sieht ja aktuell bei den Preisen aus
und weil die Leute alle auch Dank Inflation und drumherum kein Geld haben, dass es nicht
instant ausverkauft ist. Das heißt ich werde einfach mal abwarten, mir in Ruhe Tests durchlesen
bevor ich mir was Neues kaufe und vielleicht kaufe ich mir auch gar nichts.
Sind die denn lieferbar überhaupt? Rützen. Tatsächlich lieferbar. Ja, dann wird es wahrscheinlich,
dann kommt denn Intel, Leute wisst ihr wann Intel um die Ecke kommt mit irgendwas neuem?
Weil ich weiß gar nicht ob es unbedingt AMD sein wird. Ich wollte mir das letzte Mal
schon einen AMD Rechner kaufen, aber ich habe mir dann gar keinen Rechner gekauft. Aber
ich hätte mal wieder Bock drauf ein AMD System zu haben. Raptor Lake. Wahrscheinlich macht
Intel das was Intel gut kann noch mehr Strom verbrauchen. Wie findest du eigentlich die
PCs von Hardwarerad? Also das letzte Mal als ich mir die angeguckt habe, waren die preisleistungsmäßig
wirklich gut. Allerdings hätte ich mir die nicht gekauft, weil ich selbst Rechner zusammenbauen
will und ich ja da keine Shops habe ich jetzt nichts interessiert. Aber preisleistungsmäßig
waren die wirklich gut, weil man keinen Bock hat selbst zu bauen.
Ich habe auch seit 5 Jahren nichts neues gekauft. Und das Schlimme ist, ich habe seit 5 Jahren
den Rechner und der Rechner ist immer noch super. Das habe ich noch nie gehabt, das
hat es früher auch nicht gegeben. Früher war es nach eineinhalb Jahren war das Ding
langsam und nach zwei Jahren unbenutzbar langsam. Also das nicht. Es hat sich da, da hat sich
einiges geändert. Achso wir wollten ja das kurz angucken.
Okay das ist langweilig, der labert wieder nur im Kreis rum. Ja.
Raptor Lake. Naja mal schauen, mal schauen. Wie gesagt ich habe es ja eigentlich nicht
eilig. This is why I love Linux. Arch by the way. Selbstverständlich was sonst. Ubuntu
oder Fedora nehmen? Entscheidungshilfe gar nicht. Arch by the way. Und auf dem Server
stellt sich die Frage gar nicht wer nimmt Fedora auf dem Server, da bleibt ja nur noch
Ubuntu übrig. Okay was, was gucken wir uns denn an. So viel verdient man als Einsteiger
im Onlinehandel. Na dann auf geht's. Was ist das für eine Schriftart? MonkaS. So viel
verdient man als Einsteiger im Onlinehandel. Zeig mal her. Big stonks time. Hacker man.
Kein ist was anderes als Millionär zu sein. Hast du auf dem Schirm, dass wir in vier
Minuten einen Termin haben mit dem Fördermanagement? Ich bin glücklich, dass ich es geschafft
habe auch ohne ein Studium so weit zu kommen. Aha. Ja hey ich bin David, ich bin 20 Jahre
alt und ich arbeite als Junior E-Commerce Manager in Dortmund. Das ist dieser Sender,
der wieder sein Audio nicht richtig abmischen kann, wo das Audio viel lauter ist als das
was die Leute reden. Und wechselst du zu Windows 11, sobald Windows 10 nicht mehr supportet
wird oder Windows 11 irgendwas bekommt, was ich unbedingt haben will. Hi, grüß dich.
Morgen. Ich freue mich immer auf die Arbeit, ich bin morgens sehr motiviert. Guten Morgen,
ich hab die mal mitgebracht. So lass mal kurz das Setup checken. Zwei, was sind das, 22
Zoll, äh nee, vielleicht. Zwei Monitore, schon mal gut. So eine flache Tastatur wäre
für mich persönlich nichts, aber Geschmackssache. Aber wenigstens, und da bin ich schon mal
froh, wenigstens mal einer, der Maus und Tastatur hat. Wisst ihr, das irritiert mich immer bei
diesen ganzen Apple, Google, Facebook, Meta, Netflix, Software Engineer Videos, dass die
alle mit Trackpad und eingebauter Laptop Tastatur arbeiten. Ich könnte im Leben nicht mit einer
eingebauten Tastatur im Notebook den ganzen Tag arbeiten. Schau doch mal wann der Intel
i7, ok, i7 13, was soll ich danach, 13 700K. Nee. Release. Ab 20 zum Zehntem. Hoher Boost
Takt 5,4. Wisst ihr was der Witz ist? Ich hab mein 8700K übertaktiv auf 5,2 und damit
ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man rein mal die Single Core Performance nehmen würde und
vergleichen, ist wahrscheinlich mein 8700K nur, naja, da ist natürlich ein paar CPU
Generationen dazwischen, die werden noch ein paar andere Sachen jetzt, die werden noch
ein paar andere Sachen machen, aber wahrscheinlich ist meine CPU irgendwie nur 20% langsamer
oder so. So, wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben? Ok, S. Also. Meine Hauptaufgabe ist den Kunden
einen Zugang zu ermöglichen, um Ladestationen zu kaufen, über zum Beispiel eine Webseite,
ein Shop, wir arbeiten im B2B, das heißt, dass wir mal ein Unternehmen verkaufen. Dongs.
Ja, meine, achja übrigens Leute, meine Ladestation ist mittlerweile installiert. Hab ich euch
glaube ich gar nicht erzählen, ich hab's ja endlich jetzt geschafft, dass ich im Hof
eine Ladestation, so ein Charge-Wallbox-Ding habe für mein Auto und zwar ich hab die hier,
die Go-Charger, dieses Teil hier, für meinen Tesla genau, für meinen kleinen Tesla, das
da, das Teil, ja, das hat eine API, korrekt, das hat eine App, die ist aber, ja die ist
ok tatsächlich. Woher kam der Elektriker? Ich hab 8 Elektriker bei mir in der Nähe angerufen
und einer hat gesagt, achja ok, das ist ja nur was kleines, das machen wir. Die anderen
haben irgendwelchen Blödsinn erzählt teilweise, ich brauch noch einen extra Zähler und so
ein Blödsinn. Ich sag, nein, brauch ich nicht. Wozu? So, also das Teil hab ich jetzt an der
Wand und das Schöne ist, das hat, wartet mal, weiß nicht ob's hier steht, man kann das
lokal über HTTP, AP und MQTT bedienen und Informationen darüber bekommen, das ist natürlich
sehr praktisch. Und ich hab jetzt Automatisierungen bei mir am Start, kann ich euch mal ein Bild
von zeigen? Es ist, es ist, ups, ich glaub es ist E-Go-Charger, nee, oder Go-E-Charger,
nee es ist Go-E-Charger, ach keine Ahnung. Ja, und zwar ich zeig euch mal ein Bild von
meinen Automatisierungen. Sowas hab ich jetzt eingerichtet, guckt, also das erste ist,
das erste was ich eingerichtet habe ist, alle 15 Minuten wird geguckt, ist mein Charger
gerade am Chargen, also sprich ist der aktuelle, ist die Power, heißt das auf deutsch Leistung,
über 50 Watt, dann, also das ist ein Trigger, der läuft alle 15 Minuten, wenn die aktuelle
Leistung von diesem Ding über 50 Watt ist, dann refresh da über mein Addon den Batteriestatus
vom Auto, das nennt sich in Fiat Language Deep Refresh, also der aktualisiert alle 15
Minuten den Batteriestatus vom Auto, also ruft sich den neuen Batteriestatus ab, sodass
ich das immer schön auf dem Handy, auf dem Dashboard und sowas sehe. So, und das zweite
ist, die zweite Automatisierung, die ich hab, wenn der Charger-State zu Completed wechselt
für mehr als 5 Sekunden, also sprich wenn das Ding fertig geladen ist, also wenn die
Ladestation sagt, okay, State is Completed, also ich hab fertig geladen, dann refresh
dann den Batteriestatus, warte 30 Sekunden und dann schickt er mir eine Nachricht ans
Handy mit, das müsste ich jetzt mal aufklappen, dass ich euch besser zeigen kann, aber das
ist ja nur ein Bild, ich krieg dann eine Nachricht geschickt ans Handy, Auto hat fertig geladen,
inklusive Zeit wie lang es geladen hat, und das alles unabhängig von irgendwelchen Hersteller-Apps
und sonstigen Geschichten, da kann man noch viel mehr machen, deswegen war es mir wichtig,
dass mein Charger irgendeine API hat, die man abfragen kann, um solche Sachen zu machen,
ja mein Auto kann ich abfragen mit meinem selbst entwickelten Addon, was mittlerweile
anscheinend tatsächlich, einige benutzen, man 16 Sterne wahrscheinlich, mindestens mal
16 Benutzer, schau dir EVCC auf GitHub an, ich hab keine Solaranlage, das lohnt sich
aktuell wenig, wieso wartet der 30 Sekunden, der wartet 30 Sekunden, weil es sein kann,
dass der Fiat Web Service langsam ist und das Refreshen der Batterie mal ein bisschen
hängt, und wenn ich 30 Sekunden warte, dann bin ich mir sicher, das heißt, dann hat das
es aktualisiert, kann ich mir zu 90% sicher sein, dass es aktualisiert hat, weil ansonsten
würde ich eine Nachricht bekommen, es hat fertig geladen, Batteriestand 99% oder so,
das ist ja Blödsinn, ich will ja Batteriestand 100% angezeigt kriegen, wenn er sagt fertig
geladen.
Kannst du eigentlich an jeder Ladesäule laden, ja an so gut wie jeder Ladesäule, der hat
diesen ganz normalen Standard Stecker inklusive diesem Schnelllade Stecker, Top Typ 2 Stecker
ist das, es gibt ja diesen normalen Lade Stecker, also quasi diesen runden, und dann gibt es
dieses Schnelllade Ding, das ist dann unten noch diese zwei Kontakte dabei, ich kann theoretisch
an jede Ladesäule, die Frage ist, also rein vom Stecker her kann ich nahezu jede Ladesäule,
aber mit dem Bezahlen ist dann halt das Ding, da gibt es ja verschiedene Modelle, es gibt
welche, die machen das, die sind in so einem Netz zusammen, da kannst du dann beispielsweise
diese, ja ist das Charger Plus App oder so, und so einen Pass, dann kannst du bei manchen
mit Kreditkarten bezahlen, bei manchen brauchst du irgendwie eine App, bei nur bei Lidl, wenn
du bei Lidl laden willst, brauchst du beispielsweise die Lidl Charger App, also es ist ein bisschen
Wildwuchs, es gibt leider nicht so die ultimative Sache, nimm diese eine Sache und lade überall
weil die Tarife sind dann teilweise auch unterschiedlich, also sprich, wenn du irgendwo dich angemeldet
hast in der App, dann ist es teilweise, oder manche bieten ja sogar so Abos an, so bezahle
10 Euro im Monat, dafür ist es so und so viel billiger, also sprich, es kann durchaus sein,
dass es richtig teuer ist, wenn du einfach random an eine Ladesäule fährst und sagst
dann Alter, ich bezahle jetzt direkt mit EC-Karte, falls das in dem Fall geht, es ist ein bisschen
Wildwuchs, es gibt leider keine so eine Sache für alles, das ist ein bisschen doof, aber
ich hoffe das wird sich die nächsten Jahre noch ein bisschen besser, aktuell ist es eh
das beste was du machen kannst, entweder daheim laden oder beim Ikea laden, da war ich auch
schon, beim Ikea war ich auch schon, beim Ikea ist das ganze allerdings begrenzt auf 90
Minuten, 90 Minuten ja, die fertige App bringt dir ja nichts, du brauchst dir die Datengrundlage
aller Ladesäulen in Deutschland und die müssen dann auch noch irgendwie bezahlt werden, ja
das habe ich noch nicht gemacht, aber das muss ich auch noch machen, bei uns auch allerdings
kannst du dich in der, wie heißt das, Charger Plus App oder sowas, kannst du gucken ob die
frei sind, ja also ich gehe davon aus, dass es so oder so ähnliche Sachen nächsten Jahre
über noch von mehreren Anbietern geben wird bzw. sich dieses ganze Ökosystem noch weiter
verbessert, umso mehr das verbreitet wird, man darf ja nicht, man darf sich ja auch nicht
irgendwie schönreden, Elektroauto fahren ist noch ziemlich Nische aktuell, es werden
glaube ich immer noch 90% der Autos die aktuell verkauft werden sind ganz normale Autos, also
keine Elektroautos, sind quasi nicht Elektroautos und ich glaube nur 1% der gesamten Autos sind
Elektroautos, wenn überhaupt, also es ist ziemlich ziemlich Nische, ja gut umweltfreundlich,
das steht und fällt halt einzig und allein damit, also nicht einzig und allein, natürlich
ist ja auch die Herstellung ein Faktor, aber das steht und fällt zum größten Teil damit,
wie der Strom hergestellt wird, also wenn du den Strom den du lädst herstellst mit irgendwelchem
umweltschädlichen Kram, dann ist es auch nicht wirklich viel besser, der einzige Vorteil
ist den ich sehe ist, dass es weniger Smog und Umweltverschmutzung in der Innenstadt
gibt mit Elektroautos, was natürlich auch nicht verkehrt ist und gut bei der Herstellung
ist halt wieder so ein anderes Thema, also sprich aus was sind die Autos hergestellt,
aber ich denke trotzdem, dass sich Elektroautos trotz des Preises weiter durchsetzen werden,
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, das könnte ich mir aber relativ easy ausrechnen,
ja ich kenne die habe ich auch installiert, jaja das ist somit die beste App die es für
sowas gibt, neben den 80 anderen, so, Leute geht mir nicht auf den Zack, jetzt muss ich
mich mal wirklich aufregen, die Art und Weise wie manche Leute immer diskutieren und schreiben
fuckt mich übelst ab, ja ich sag hier meine Meinung, ich habe nichts dagegen wenn einer
was anderes sagt, aber diese Art und Weise so zu schreiben ist einfach absoluter Abfuck,
das ist genauso wie wenn ich im Stream irgendwas ausprobiere und dann irgendwelche Leute um
die Ecke kommen, wie hast du nicht gesehen alter bist du blöd, Zeile 15 ist falsch,
das regt mich unglaublich auf, schreibt es normal und geht mir nicht auf den Sack, so
das muss ich jetzt einfach mal loswerden, also manche Art und Weise von Leuten regt mich
unglaublich auf, ich habe nichts dagegen wenn die Leute das anders sehen, ist ja gut, muss
sein das ging nicht anders, und auch die Antwort darauf, Leute was ist denn los, guckt mal
sobald der erste anfängt sich aufzuregen wird das so eine unglaublich unsachliche wahnsinnig
hitzige Diskussion, das ist das einzige was das bringt, das sorgt weder dafür dass man
irgendjemand davon überzeugt, es kann ja durchaus sein dass jemand das falsch sieht
oder vielleicht manche Gesichtspunkte das noch nicht realisiert hat, dass es vielleicht
anders ist, aber so wirst du, kann ich dich überzeugen und das provoziert eher so Antworten,
das ist halt einfach bescheuert, so, weiß ich gar nicht wo ich stehen geblieben bin,
egal, enraged jetzt, das muss echt nicht sein, jetzt habe ich ganz vergessen was ich eigentlich
sagen wollte, ja genau also diese App ist tatsächlich die beste App die ich bisher gefunden
habe, das stimmt schon was, wo ist das charger App, ja das ist das die habe ich auch, es
gibt 80 verschiedene solche Apps, ich habe mir auch schon überlegt ob ich mir nicht
so eine charge pass holen soll, am besten ist natürlich kostenlos laden beim Ikea, ja und
eine Sache das genau jetzt weiß ich was ich sagen wollte, das geht tatsächlich so ein
bisschen in die Richtung dass da nicht alles rosig ist bei, eine Sache sollte man aber
nicht vergessen, wenn man ein Auto hat, egal was, es ist in der Regel immer billiger das
alte Auto oder was ist das nicht, billiger, billiger nicht zwangsläufig, umweltfreundlicher
das alte Auto zu behalten, weil wenn man sich überlegt was es eben an Ressourcen braucht
ein neues Auto herzustellen versus das alte Auto einfach weiter zu betreiben ist das eigentlich
immer besser, also wenn man sich denkt alter ich habe ein altes Auto das ist jetzt nicht
mehr so modern und super umweltschädlich, ich kaufe mir ein neues dann ist es in der
Regel immer die falsche Entscheidung rein aus Umweltsicht, aber trotzdem ich hatte keinen
Bock mehr auf mein altes Auto, ich wollte mir ein neues Auto kaufen zumal mein altes
Auto auch den Geist aufgegeben hat, das stimmt wohl, das ist richtig, wenn du Quick Charging
machst dann ist das erstmal nicht so gut für den Akku, aber ganz im Ernst da gibt
es ja viele Sachen nachdem man es nicht so schnell laden soll, man soll das so und so
machen und nicht so voll laden, ganz im Ernst ich weiß nicht ob es da irgendwelche Untersuchungen
zu gibt, also dass es so ist ja, aber es ist halt die Frage wieviel macht es wirklich aus
und wenn es im Endeffekt über 10 Jahre keine Ahnung 2% Akkuleistung ausmacht dann würde
ich sagen draufgeschissen, ist halt die Frage wieviel es wirklich ist, machst du schon länger
oder nimmst du, ich mache ich, ja das mache ich länger, jaja das mache ich länger, das
mache ich seit Jahren schon, dass ich komplett im Dezember Urlaub habe, ich fahre dann auch
meistens nicht in den Urlaub, das höchste der Gefühle war dass ich den Fabian in Dresden
oder so besucht habe, ich mache dann einfach Youtube und Twitch und Zeugs und Steuererklärung
und so gedönst mache ich im Dezember.
Der Gebrauchmarkt ist generell ziemlich hochpreisig aktuell, also es kostet alles wahnsinnig viel
Geld, auch gebrauchte Autos, ja mit einfach ausfüllen ist das nicht getan, du musst erst
mal gucken was du da genau reinschreiben musst, so wieviel Tage Urlaub hast du im Jahr, gute
Frage, normalerweise, ich glaube normalerweise 30, aber ich arbeite nur 4 Tage, also habe
ich nur, ja zieht mal 20% ab, also 24 oder so, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich 24, geraten
ich weiß es nicht, so, jetzt gucken wir mal weiter, wo sind wir, was wollten wir uns eigentlich
angucken, hier, den E-Commerce, wir fangen nochmal von vorne an, ich habe mich jetzt
zu sehr ablenken lassen, 24 Tage ist gesetzliches Minimum, ja ja für 100% arbeiten, ich habe
24 Tage weil ich nur 4 Tage arbeite, wenn du nur 1 Tag arbeitest hast du auch anteilmäßig
weniger, nee nee nee nee, oder keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht, nee nee nee es ist wirklich
weniger, ich glaube ich habe 24 Tage, normal 30 und ich habe 24, weil 10% von 30 ist 3,
20% von 30 ist 6 und dementsprechend 30-6 sind 24, also müsste ich 24 haben, so, aber
wir gucken jetzt mal, nein, das da, so der E-Commerce Manager, auf gehts, finanziell
frei sein ist was anderes als Millionär zu sein, hast du, ja und frei sein ist sicherlich
auch was das bedeutet, ein variabler Begriff, ich bin glücklich, dass ich es geschafft
habe auch ohne ein Studium so weit zu kommen, ja hey ich bin David, ich bin 20 Jahre alt
und ich arbeite als Junior E-Commerce Manager in Dortmund, so und sie verkaufen Ladestationen,
jetzt weiß ich auch wie ich wieder darauf gekommen bin, weil sie Ladestationen verkaufen,
ich freue mich immer auf die Arbeit, ich bin sehr motiviert, das sagt er doch nur, weil
sein Chef zuguckt, oder, mal ganz einfach, kann er wirklich sein, kann er, ohne Scheiß,
kann er wirklich sein, ups, guten Morgen, habe ich mal mitgebracht, sitzt er gegenüber
von seiner Chefin und wird den ganzen Tag beobachtet, ein bisschen beilm, ja wir sind
ein bisschen spät dran, meine Hauptaufgabe ist den Kunden einen Zugang zu ermöglichen
um Ladestationen, wie die das schon sagt, das wird mich triggern Alter, ein bisschen
beilm, hört euch das mal an, ja wir sind ein bisschen spät dran, ok ich kenne sie nicht,
vielleicht ist das auch einfach nett gemeint, kann ja sein, meine Hauptaufgabe ist den Kunden
einen Zugang zu ermöglichen um Ladestationen zu kaufen, über zum Beispiel eine Webseite,
wir arbeiten im B2B, das heißt, dass wir nur an Unternehmen kaufen, Business to Business,
Cat Jam, David hast du auf dem Schirm, dass wir in 4 Minuten den Termin haben, ja klar,
ich habe schon mit der Asphalt Liner auch vorgesprochen und alles vorbereitet, eigentlich
müsste die Tübeten sagen, hi welcher Termin, ich muss jetzt erst weg, oder irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung, wie ich kann jetzt nicht, ich muss jetzt runter noch mal umparken, war
kein Platz am Charger frei, keck lief, 48 unser Daily Meeting, da besprechen wir im
Team, wer was gestern geschafft hat und was wir heute schaffen, damit man einen Überblick
hat woran gerade gearbeitet wird, wisst ihr was ich geil finde, das haben wir ja früher
wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe, da hatten die ja auch diese, wie haben sie es genannt,
Daily, keine Ahnung, Daily Status oder so, also mit Daily Scrum hat es ja nichts zu tun,
viele nennen das so und ich muss euch sagen, ich glaube nicht einmal, nicht einmal habe
ich dort was erfahren, wo ich gesagt hätte, ach ja daran arbeitest du also, ah sehr interessant,
ja das hat mir jetzt wirklich was gebracht, als ich das erfahren habe, zumindest nicht
einmal an das ich mich erinnern kann, das nehmen wir mit, wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck
dran, ja genau, meistens arten diese Meetings immer zu Selbstdarstellungsterminen aus,
so nach dem Motto, gestern habe ich das und das abgeschlossen, ich habe das in die Wege
geleitet, ich habe das hier noch mal vermittelt, das und das und das und im Endeffekt läuft
es darauf raus, du hast Leute, die 90% der Redezeit in Anspruch nehmen und sich dann
halt als die geilsten Checker der Welt hinstellen und die anderen denken sich, alter ist dieses
Meeting endlich mal bald vorbei, ja, aber es heißt nicht, dass sowas prinzipiell unsinnig
sein muss, das ist halt die Frage, wie es gemacht ist, wenn es Runden gibt, so nach
dem Motto, Jungs, lass mal kurz gucken, gibt es irgendwas spannendes, was man wissen muss
und es ist vollkommen okay, man sagt nichts, genau, Max möchtest du heute Protokoll schreiben
fürs Meeting, das wurde ja damals beim Provider auch gemacht, es wurde jedes Daily, was eigentlich
so nur als schnelle Übersicht gedacht war, wurde ein fucking Protokoll geschrieben und
als ich noch Azubi war, musste ich quasi jeden Tag dieses dumme Protokoll schreiben, das
war ganz schlimm, das war wirklich abartig, Daily Meeting, so nach dem Motto, Jungs, gibt
es irgendwas spannendes, Neues, was man wissen müsste, ne, ne, gibt nichts, ach hier, ich
hab gehört, morgen machen sie einen USV-Test, kann sein, dass es kurz ruckelt, ah, okay,
alles klar, das finde ich gut, das finde ich in Ordnung, ja, wenn es Daily Meetings gibt,
wo es okay ist, nichts zu sagen oder wo es fast schon Standard ist, nichts zu sagen,
weil es ist halt einfach so, es passiert nicht an fünf Tagen die Woche irgendwas spannendes
von jedem, was jeder wissen müsste.
Ja, Anba dran, das kann sinnvoll sein, aber es darf nicht in diese Selbstdarstellungs-
beziehungsweise wer nichts erzählt hat, angeblich nichts geschafft, Meetings ausarten und das
ist zumindest so wie ich es erlebt habe, ich meine, ich hab jetzt auch nicht irgendwie
150 Arbeitgeber durch, bei vielen der Fall und das finde ich halt blödsinnig, so das,
was ich gerade gesagt hab, so dieses, lass uns mal kurz abstimmen, gibt es irgendwas
wichtiges, was man wissen muss oder gibt es irgendwie was spannendes, das finde ich vollkommen
in Ordnung, aber es muss halt auch okay sein, dass man sagt, also, außerdem Standard-Gramm
ist jetzt nichts Wichtiges, was irgendwie spannend ist, dann ist okay, dann ist das
nach zwei Minuten fertig.
Ja, genau das man quasi sich gezwungen fühlt, was zu sagen, das finde ich, das finde ich
immer blöd und das haben gerade so offizielle Meetings im Zweifelsfall auch mit Protokoll
dann immer so an sich, hat jetzt mit dem Video nur am Rande was zu tun, wie gesagt, was
ich gut finde, ist so, lass mal kurz gucken, irgendwas spannendes, dann erfährst du zum
Beispiel sowas wie, hier hast du schon das neueste Organikramm gesehen, auch wusstest
du, die machen jetzt einen USV-Test, ah, übrigens, hier ist gar ne neue Version, die ist da
und da verbackt, das ist alles in Ordnung, da sag ich überhaupt nichts, oder zum Beispiel
hier hab ich euch schon erzählt, die Telekom hat wieder ihr Zeug kaputt gemacht oder ja,
es kann sein, es gibt ja immer ab und zu mal ganz interessante Sachen so, ah ja, es kann
sein, dass hier demnächst der und der bei dir vorbeikommt, was wissen will, der war letzte
Woche auch bei mir, das ist super, so aktuelles Status-Updates, gibt es irgendwelche spannenden
Sachen, ja da kann ja beispielsweise auch mal einer erzählen, Jungs, ich hab jetzt dafür
gesorgt, dass bei jedem Login auf jedem Linux-System, äh, was weiß ich, irgendwie ein neues Banner
angezeigt wird oder so, ja, also das ist ja alles in Ordnung, aber so diese gezwungenen
Sachen, gerade mit Protokoll, die finde ich immer so, ja, da so gezwungen so und jeder
denkt, er muss da jetzt was zu sagen, weil ansonsten denken alle, er macht nix, ja, das
sind so Meetings, das finde ich immer relativ unsinnig, so und es ist halt wie gesagt, als
ich dieses Daily mit Protokoll, was wir früher beim Provider machen mussten, ich sag ja immer
nicht die Namen, wo ich bin, ja, das war nie irgendwas spannendes, das war reine Selbstdarstellung
für die Leute, dass die erzählen konnten, was tolles gemacht haben, beziehungsweise
dass der Chef sieht, die machen was und ich hab da nie was erfahren, was mich irgendwie
interessiert hätte.
So, weiter, jetzt gucken wir uns das Video an, so, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben,
8.40 Uhr, Daily, Daily heiße Luft, Daily heiße Luft, ich hab vor heute im Bereich News,
die Webinartermine aufzubereiten, dann werde ich einmal die Events anpassen, genau, das
wäre jetzt so eine Aussage gewesen, wo ich mir halt so denke, ok, was juckt's mich, who
cares, warum muss ich das wissen, was interessiert's mich, wenn ich beispielsweise gerade damit
beschäftigt bin, keine Ahnung, irgendwie, auf der Webseite irgendwelche neuen Bildchen
hochzuladen oder so, was interessiert's mich, ja, was juckt's, das ist gut, das ist wichtig,
das muss gemacht werden, sag ich ja nix dagegen, man sagt ja auch nicht, das ist unwichtig,
aber das interessiert niemand, der in diesem Meeting ist, wette ich mit euch, ich mein,
er muss es erzählen, an ihm liegt das ja nicht, er muss es erzählen, weil seine Chefin wahrscheinlich
sonst sagen würde, machst du denn gar nix, aber die anderen, die in diesem Meeting sitzen,
ja, der eine arbeitet vielleicht an der Webseite, der andere checkt den Warenbestand, dem ist
das vollkommen egal, ob das Webinar demnächst eine 1 oder eine 2 vorne stehen hat.
Dann würde ich übergeben an Ann-Kathrin, ich wollte jetzt wissen, was Ann-Kathrin macht,
dass ich meinen Tagesablauf besser planen kann, Content und jetzt kopiere ich gerade
den Quellcode und hoffe, dass sich der Quellcode vernünftig überträgt, sodass die ganzen
Bilder und Texte richtig formatiert werden.
Keck, Moment, was?
Ah, das ist irgend so ein WordPress oder sowas in der Richtung, nee, das ist irgendwas selbst
entwickeltes von denen, ok, ja, irgend so ein CMS, irgend ein CMS, wo ATML-Gedöns rein,
ist das Typo 3, Shopware, nee, was?
Hier so heißt er wahrscheinlich, Administrator ist er, das ist Shopware, woran erkennt ihr
das Chat, ich kenne mich mit diesem System nicht aus, woran, so am Layout oder woran
erkennt ihr das, Logo, ach, ich dachte, das ist das Logo von den in ihre Hymne, ist das
Shopware-Logo, ach, wirklich, Shopware, ach ja, offensichtlich ist das Shopware, ja,
das ist auch von irgendeinem Deutschen gegründet, glaubt, gell, Shopware, nee, Shopify, Shopify,
Shopware ist wieder was anderes, Shopify ist, glaubt, von irgendeinem Deutschen gegründet,
also so internationale Shopping-Store.
90% wird scheiße gelabert in den Meetings, ja, ist so, ist so, bekommst du genau richtig
mit.
Ok, also er kopiert, ok, er kopiert quasi neues, neuen Content, Typo 3-Uhr, ja, was
ist es denn jetzt, ist es Shopware, haben die Typo 3 als, ich will es eigentlich, eigentlich
ist es mir egal, weil ich wusste den Kram eh nicht, alle CMS-Gedöns, genau, CMS-Gedöns
mit, ähm, warum genau fügt man da bitte schön HTML in so einem VisiWig-Editor ein,
was ist denn das für ein komisches CMS, was passiert denn, wenn ich das HTML fett mache,
ist es dann, fett, oder, ja, überträgt, sodass die ganzen Bilder und Texte richtig
formatiert werden, einmal speichern und dann schaue ich, ob sich das alles richtig übertragen
hat.
Schlimmste Szenario ist, dass die Plattform plötzlich gar nicht mehr funktioniert und
man erstmal herausfinden muss, ok, woran liegt das, wo ist das Problem, das Problem liegt
wahrscheinlich daran, dass das irgendwas in der Cloud gehostet ist und wenn der Hersteller
gerade keinen Bock mehr hat oder Probleme hat, dann ist der Job halt einfach weg.
Wo ist das Problem?
Manchmal kann es halt eben passieren, dass bei der Übertragung nicht die Links korrekt
sozusagen mit übertragen werden und dann kann es dazu Fehlern kommen.
Ich werde das jetzt noch meiner Kollegin einmal überprüfen lassen.
Das sieht soweit gut aus.
Hier ist alles wunderbar.
Das ist doch super.
Oh Gott, naja, super, das ist eine super Teamarbeit.
Wahnsinn!
Ctrl C, Ctrl V, ach ja, sieht gut gepastet aus, nice, super, MonkaS, Alter, ok, natürlich,
ich will jetzt nicht ganz so gemein sein, es ist gestellt für das, weil daneben des
Kamerateams steht, ja klar, das wird auch nicht das sein, was er den ganzen Tag macht.
Sprache C++ gelernt, so wie Java, in der Schule hat es nicht so Spaß gemacht tatsächlich,
da es sehr fachlich war, jetzt kann ich es aber im Beruf, in der Praxis einmal umsetzen
und...
Ja gut, das ist weder Java noch C++, aber gut, nein, viel schlimmer kann es ja nicht
sein, mit Java und C++ angefangen, dass man dann keinen Bock mehr drauf hat, kann ich
verstehen.
Also was hat er gemacht?
Ausbildungsabschluss, ja, Ausbildung, Informationstechnik, aha, Fachabitur, das ist halt auch komplett
unsinnig, ja, also falsch, dass das ist, was ich mir denke, es ist das, was einige Leute
nach der Schule machen, weil sie nicht wissen, was sie sonst machen sollen, allerdings ist
absolut nichts bringt, sie hätten es auch genauso sein lassen können.
Danach Fachabi gemacht, und jetzt ist er Junior E-Commerce Manager, was ist so schlimm als
C++?
Soll ich wirklich mit diesem Thema wieder anfangen, Chat?
Ne, das machen wir heute nicht, wenn ich damit jetzt anfange, dann machen wir in dem Stream
nichts anderes mehr, nein, nein, nein, nein, damit fange ich nicht wieder an.
Nein, nein, nein, das mach ich nicht, wenn ich davon anfange, mache ich im Stream nichts
anderes.
Okay, ich arbeite 40 Stunden die Woche, ich habe die Möglichkeit, flexibel meine Arbeitszeit
einzuteilen.
Wisst ihr, sowas, was wir jetzt von ihm gesehen haben, alles, das könnt ihr ohne Probleme
von daheim aus machen, komplett, also es macht keinen Sinn, dass der auf die Arbeit kommen
muss, aber ich wette mit euch, das ist bei denen wahrscheinlich kein Thema, weil der
Chef da nicht gucken kann über den Bildschirm, was macht er eigentlich gerade?
Wir anfangen aber auch um 12 Uhr erst anfangen und um 18 Uhr aufhören.
Ich investiere in Einzelaktien, ich habe vor kurzem eine große Summe investiert, es ist
im Endeffekt wie Lotto spielen, man kann nicht wissen, ob es nach oben oder nach unten gehen
wird.
Warum machst du es trotzdem?
Man kann auch ETFs kaufen und eigentlich auf der sicheren Seite sein, außer dieses Jahr.
Leute, meine Stonks sind glaube ich mittlerweile schon bei minus 3000 Euro oder so dieses Jahr.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wartet mal.
Oh nee, mein Login ist wieder abgelaufen, muss ich mir erst wieder einloggen.
Also meine Stonks sind dieses Jahr nicht gut.
Weil das Interesse für die Unternehmen da sind, in die ich investiere.
Wie sieht es mit dem Essen aus, mit dem Essen bestellen?
Ja, wir haben überlegt, dass wir was bestellen.
China-Chinesen, nee, nee.
Öko-Essen.
12,90 Alter, what the fuck?
Das Zeug ist teuer geworden, ja.
Ich überlege noch, ich konnte sogar in Frankfurt, also vor Corona, als ich ja noch regelmäßig
war, ich konnte quasi in Frankfurt ein Mittagsmenü futtern beim China-Chines bei uns um die
Ecke für glaube 6,50 und Frankfurt ist sicherlich schon nicht das billigste gewesen.
Wie ein schlechtes Gewissen, das Corona war.
6,50 gab es einmal fried rice.
Ich hab mich noch nie gegen die Leckofunnyball entschieden, jedes Mal die Leckofunnyball.
Eine Bowl gibt es meistens so ein bis zwei Mal im Monat, ist für mich ein Highlight.
Aufnimm ich mein Frühstück mit zur Arbeit und esse das dann meistens so.
Die Stühle sehen äußerst unbequem aus.
12 Uhr.
Ich mein, guck mal, du hast dir irgendwie gefühlt, du musst dir halb auf den Tisch
legen, dass du an dein Essen rankommst.
Du bist ja quasi mit dem Bein direkt am Tisch.
Okay, das ist jetzt so eine Einstellungs-Sache.
Ich mag so Mittagessen mit random Leuten, ich will meine Ruhe haben.
Ich futter mittlerweile sogar, ihr wisst, ich bin, was soziale Sachen angeht, nicht so,
ja, ihr kennt mich, ihr kennt mich.
Ja, Chet, ihr habt recht, alles hotte Dudes, ja, Gatschi-Buzz.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Einstellungskriterium da.
Du musst stylisch aussehen, alles hotte Dudes.
Zumindest, ich futter mittlerweile sogar mein Mittagessen am Platz und will meine Ruhe
haben.
Wir haben eine Plattform für Kunden und da haben wir einen Bereich News.
Meine Aufgabe ist gleich, einen weiteren Beitrag zu ergänzen, News, die dann keiner
liest.
Im Artikel geht es darum, dass wir für die Kunden eine neue Möglichkeit haben, den Status
von der Ladesäule auszulesen.
Ach so, es ist quasi so eine Art Change-Log, ja doch, das würde ich dann doch lesen.
Wait a minute, das ist Cloud-based Ladestation oder wie?
Also sprich, die Leute können es selbst nicht auslesen, nur über die Cloud, na toll.
Schief gehen kann, dass es gar nicht übertragen geht im Vordergrund für die Kunden, genauso
können es Formatierungs-Fehler sein.
Leute, ich meinte vor allem auch die, die beim Mittagessen noch dabei waren.
Aber, die sehen doch alle schnittig aus, das musste wahrscheinlich im Online-Marketing.
Du musst erstmal was hermachen.
Jetzt sollte hoffentlich, wenn alles geklappt hat, im Vordergrund dann für die Kunden das
sichtbar sein, was ich jetzt im Backend umgesetzt habe.
Auf geht's.
Wie wir sehen, ist jetzt auch der News-Beitrag im Vordergrund zu sehen für die Kunden, also
es hat alles super geklappt.
Das ist schon mal ein schönes Teil hier oft drauf.
Im April dieses Jahres ist er erst angefangen, sprich er ist jetzt ein halbes Jahr hier und
hat sich unheimlich toll entwickelt, übernimmt Verantwortung, ist wirklich für das Team
eine Entlastung, hilft uns, neue Ideen zu entwickeln, das ist super.
Also ich verdiene im Monat ca.
2900 Euro brutto, das sind ungefähr 1900 Euro netto und je nach …
Das ist aber ein bisschen … naja …
Zielerreichung habe ich die Möglichkeit noch ein 13.
Monatsgehalt zu erhalten.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht so viel.
Ich finde es super, dass es eine Zielprämie gibt und …
Vor allem für 100% Anwesenheit im Büro oder würde ich … ne, das würde ich nicht machen.
Ich versuche natürlich die 100% abzustauben, für mein Alter und für meine Berufserfahrung
bin ich sehr zufrieden damit.
Die Möglichkeit ein 13es Gehalt zu erreichen, ja, ja, das gibt es tatsächlich relativ oft,
es gibt bei uns auch sowas, also wir kriegen ja standardmäßig 14 Monatsgehälter, nicht
12, bei uns sind standardmäßig 14, das sieht bei uns folgendermaßen aus, wir bekommen,
ich weiß gar nicht genau wann, ich glaube an Ostern und an Weihnachten kriegen wir doppelt
das Gehalt, wir haben aber die Möglichkeit auf 14,8 Monatsgehälter, das ist dann gebunden
an … natürlich nichts individuelles, das wäre deutlich zu modern für die Firma, wo
ich arbeite, ne, ne, das ist für irgendwelche IT erreicht Gesamtziele irgendwie gekoppelt,
keine Ahnung, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde das, ich finde das ein bisschen
wenig, weil das ist ungefähr mein Einstiegsgehalt gewesen, allerdings das war 2009, 10, 9, irgendwie
im Dreh, also ich habe quasi mehr oder weniger das gleiche Einstiegsgehalt gekriegt vor
15 Jahren, also das hätte ich jetzt schon erwartet, gut, ich meine, das ist auch komplett
anderer Beruf, ja, muss man sagen, aber trotzdem, so happy wäre ich jetzt persönlich damit
nicht, aber wichtig ist ja natürlich, dass das bei ihm alles gut läuft drumherum und
wenn ihm das Spaß macht, ist das auch viel wert.
Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen eng geparkt, aber erst mal fetten BMW, wichtig, oder wie letztens
mein Friseur zu mir gesagt hat, warum Fiat, du könntest doch AMG fahren, hat sie letztens
erzählt, hatten wir es davon, dass ich mir ein neues Auto gekauft habe, also warum Fiat,
du könntest doch AMG fahren, Mama ist die Beste, das finde ich nice, jawoll, das würde
ich mir jetzt auch reinhauen, Pepo-Fat-Time, Dorian, du musst dich nicht sehen, das ist
nicht live, hi Dorian, naja, das wird auf jeden Fall irgendwann ausgestrahlt, ist auch
egal, ob es jetzt live ist oder nicht, ich wohne gerne zu Hause, ich auch, vor allem,
weil das Haus mir gehört, Sinn macht zu Hause zu wohnen, ich muss nicht zur Miete beitragen
und ich wohne auch gerne zu Hause, meine Mutter sagt das immer wieder, dass ich so lange bleiben
kann, wie ich will, würde ich auch, ohne Mist, warum nicht, ist doch wunderbar, ganz im Ernst,
das hat eigentlich nur Vorteile, du hast jemand, der aufräumt, du hast jemand, der Wäsche
macht, du hast jemand, der Essen macht, du hast jemand, der einkauft, er wird sich sicherlich
auch an den Ausgaben beteiligen, das habe ich auch jahrelang so gemacht, das Beste,
was man machen kann, das Beste, was man machen kann, gut, natürlich nur, wenn man gute Beziehung
zu seinen Eltern, das ist klar, der soll das so lange machen, wie es möglich ist, das
so lange alle anpacken, dann ist das doch schön, meine Mutter ist in Rente, ja gut,
ich bin jetzt 38 und meine Mutter ist, gute Frage, lass mal kurz in mich gehen, 71 glaube
ich, ich glaube 71, ja, genau, ja ja, die ist in Rente und das hat tatsächlich bei
uns, muss man sagen, wirklich gut funktioniert, fast auf den Tag genau, als ich mit meiner
Ausbildung fertig war, ist sie in Rente gegangen, also mit meiner zweiten Fachinformatik Ausbildung,
ihr wisst ja, dass ich mal in einem anderen Leben BWL Scheiß gelernt habe, könnt ihr
euch das vorstellen, ich und BWL, kann man, das ist eine Kombination, das kann man sich
überhaupt nicht vorstellen, oder, ich habe, ich hasse das komplett, durch und durch habe
ich da eine Abneigung dagegen, aber ich habe relativ schnell gemerkt, dass das nichts für
mich ist, ja, da konnte ich zum Glück noch Zivildienst einschieben, weil es das bei
mir noch gegeben hat und ich war eh, habe ich ja schon oft genug in Videos gesagt, ich
war ein ultra fauler Dude, bin ich immer noch, aber aktuell, ja, ist es nicht so wild, also
hat keine Nachteile, ja, ich war einfach so extrem faul, ich habe beispielsweise anstatt
nach einer Ausbildung zu suchen, lieber 24-7 MMOs gespielt und ich wollte auch nichts machen,
ich wollte einfach nur MMOs weiterspielen und irgendwann habe ich halt angefangen Bürokaufmann
zu lernen, weil, ja, eigentlich weil mir meine Eltern so auf den Sack gegangen sind
und ich easy was gefunden habe und ich habe dann aber relativ schnell gemerkt, dass will
ich nicht machen, ja, na gut und wie gesagt, da habe ich Zivildienst gemacht und dann habe
ich glücklicherweise mich mal kurzzeitig zusammengeraffen, habe gesagt, hey, du spielst jetzt einfach
nur noch 8 Stunden am Tag anstatt 16 Stunden am Tag MMOs und habe ein paar Bewerbungen
geschrieben und dann habe ich mich unter anderem bei einem, Moment, wie umschreibe ich das am
besten, wo liegen die denn, ja, bei einem süddeutschen Provider beworben und die habe
ich genommen, mein Vorstellungsgespräch war, weiß ich, sehr kurz und knackig irgendwie,
also das war eh weird champ, also ganz ehrlich, also ich habe mich da beworben in Frankfurt
und auf einmal kriege ich einen Anruf von einer Firma, also ganz woanders und da habe
ich mir gedacht, hä, was wollt ihr denn von mir, ich habe mich doch in Frankfurt beworben
und da haben die gemeint, ja, unsere Niederlassung ist ja in Frankfurt, aber wir, unser Sitz
ist ja eigentlich ganz woanders und da habe ich mir auch schon gedacht, alter, das ist
aber ziemlich sus und dann bin ich da tatsächlich doch hingefahren zum Vorstellungsgespräch
und also das war ein Test-Vorstellungsgespräch und ich hatte ja, eigentlich wollte ich das
nicht machen, ich meine, es kostet ja auch was mit dem Zug da hinzufahren und so, eigentlich
hätte ich nicht von sich aus sagen müssen, Junge, wir bezahlen dir selbstverständlich
die Anreise und so, was sie dann beim zweiten Mal hingefahren mir natürlich auch gemacht
haben, aber na gut, zumindest, ich war dann da und dann mussten wir erst so einen komischen
Test machen, der Test war, habe ich nachher rausgefunden, der Test, den die Leute machen
müssen, wenn sie dort als, damals als Admin anfangen wollen, die haben einfach für die
Azubis den gleichen Test genommen für Leute, die sie so einstellen wollten und ich konnte
tatsächlich ein paar Sachen beantworten, da war zum Beispiel auch die Frage, wie löschen
sie im Wim eine Zeile Text, war drinne, oder welche IP-Tables-Tabellen kennen sie und wie,
was ist das erste, was sie bei einem Cisco-Switch machen mussten und so was und davon konnte
ich tatsächlich manche Sachen beantworten, ich glaube, das war nicht schlecht, ich glaube,
das war nicht schlecht, ansonsten kann ich mich wenig erinnern an den Test, ach so, NAT-Geschichten
musste man noch beantworten, die haben irgendwie so Netzwerkgedüns gemalt, hatten sie hier
mit, hier da ist ein Netzwerk, da ist ein Netzwerk, da ist ein Netzwerk, so und da ist
irgendwie, das ist ein Router, so und dann haben wir da was und da was und irgendwie
diese zwei Netzwerke können nicht miteinander kommunizieren und dann war das Problem irgendwas
mit NAT, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, NAT war damals schon immer das Problem, das
habe ich reingeschrieben, anscheinend war das auch richtig, was ist Wim, ein Texteditor,
ein Texteditor, den die Leute öffnen und dann immer nicht wissen, wie sie rauskommen,
wenn sie den das erste Mal aufmachen, der ist da schon berühmt, berüchtigt dafür,
zumindest danach ging es direkt weiter zum Vorstellungsgespräch und das weiß ich heute
noch, die sind rausgekommen, haben gefragt und wer will anfangen und haben sich alle
so angeguckt, so und dann dachte ich mir so alter Leute, ich will eh wieder heim, mein
Zug fährt bald, ich gehe einfach als erster, also habe ich so nicht gesagt, ich habe einfach
gesagt ja gut dann fang ich an und dann bin ich da rein und da weiß ich noch, das war
übelst weird champ, also ich bin da reingekommen und irgendwie habe ich so die Eingebung gehabt
das war das war das war eindeutig eher kein alpha mail move das war ein ich will
wieder heim move also eigentlich ein was ist denn das wenn man wenn man zu viel
schiss hat und abhauen will move das ist das ist doch nicht mal beta move das ist
was ist das omega move oder so eigentlich wollte ich wieder heim
back to evermore grind omega move ist das definitiv auch kein sigma move zumindest
ich bin als erstes rein irgendwie hatte ich so das gefühl ich müsste jetzt was
sagen weil die saßen dann da drinnen und haben mich angeguckt und ich habe
dann halt gesagt so als erstes und das war wahrscheinlich wirklich so auch mein
glück dass das gespräch dann so gut gelaufen ist das erste was ich gesagt
habe noch bevor ich mich hingesetzt habe ist also manche fragen im test waren
wirklich gemein und schon war das gespräch eröffnet so nach dem motto die
antwort ja warum habe ich gesagt ja hier bei der ein ip tables frage ich
wusste eigentlich was reinkommt ich konnte mich aber nicht an die namen
erinnern ich mein wer kann sich das alles merken und so und dann haben sie
erzählen dann wollten sie was zu meinem dsl anschluss wissen und das ist
tatsächlich so ein tipp den ich den ich gelernt habe da ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
allgemeingültig ist aber ich glaube jetzt zumindest schlecht gerade in diesen
gesprächen wo keiner so genau weiß was er jetzt eigentlich sagen muss und im
zweifelsfall dich noch irgendwas ne also was für dich negatives fragt so
irgendwelche komischen vorstellungs fragen vor vorstellungsgespräch
fragen und ich weiß was drauf sagen soll das ist glaube ich gar nicht so
schlecht man versucht zumindest so ein bisschen das gesprächsthema zum
einstieg selbst zu wählen weil dann hat man bessere chancen dass nix gar so
unangenehmes dran kommt
ja da ging es irgendwie ein bisschen um ein dsl anschluss und was hat er mich
sonst noch gefragt ja ob ich wüsste was was man unter monitoring versteht da
habe ich ein übel cringewitz gemacht da habe ich sind sind gemäß so was
gesagt ja ich vermute mal nicht so wie im krankenhaus ich will ich meine ich
wusste dass es selber überwachung ist ja das wusste ich zum damaligen
zeitpunkt auch aber ja und zumindest bin ich dann da raus und habe ausversehen
den kuli mitgenommen den habe ich heute noch irgendwo den den
kugelschreiber ja zumindest
kuli komplett leute komplett ausversehen hat das ding in der hand ich
habe den quatsch meint ihr allen ernstes meint ihr allen ernstes ich würde
ernst ich würde im vorstellungsgespräch absichtlich schon meinen zukünftigen
eventuell arbeitgeber beklauen oder was also dass das wäre der größte blödsinn
smooth überhaupt ich habe das ich habe vergessen zumindest ich bin heraus aus
dem vorstellungsgespräch die haben dann halt gesagt ja ok alles klar dann wie
dann dann hören wir was voneinander oder irgendwas so was war total
unverbindlich ist was die gesagt haben und nächsten morgen leute ihr könnt
davon ausgehen ich habe da bis elf oder so gepennt damals noch weil danach wurde
geradet online mmo kreisel kreit und alles gemacht so und auf einmal ruft mich
irgendwie um halb acht oder um acht jemand an ich höre noch das telefon klingeln so und
was ist denn jetzt los man um die uhrzeit was wollt ihr denn von mir und da war
ein tag später schon eine frau von der personalabteilung dran von von dem von
meinem zukünftigen arbeitgeber hat gesagt ja herr max wir würden ihnen da
gerne einen vertrag zu senden oder würden sie gerne in vertrag sie quasi
einstellen nice ich muss gar nicht so genau was ich sagen sollte zumindest
habe ich den vertrag unterschrieben habe da meine ausbildung angefangen und die
ausbildung an sich war schlecht aus dem gesichtspunkt dass man halt ausgebildet
wird unterm strich war die ausbildung aber gut weil man hat viel gelernt die
ausbildung war schlecht in dem sinn es gab keine ausbildung die ausbildung war
nicht existent man saß da und sollte irgendwas machen du hattest kein ausbilder
du hattest nichts du solltest einfach dinger machen und du hattest nur die
chance entweder du lernst das jetzt weil du dich damit auseinandersetzt oder aber
du hast verkackt und bis danach drei jahren ahnungslos und ich muss sagen ich
habe in diesen drei jahren mehr gelernt was rechenzentrum sachen angeht was
linux sachen was administrations sachen angeht als jemals wieder später
ich habe in diesen drei jahren wirklich extrem viel gelernt ich behaupte einfach
mal mehr als die meisten leute in ihrer ausbildung lernen ich bin vom kak noob
zum recht fähigen admin geworden ich hatte davor schon ein bisschen ahnung von
linux aber nie so wirklich viel damit gemacht also vom absoluten linux kak
noob zu ich kenne mich recht gut aus mit linux in drei jahren und das halt im
büsnensumfeld wo es halt auch darum geht wenn du da mist baus ist halt kaputt
also ich habe wirklich viel gelernt in den drei jahren ich muss aber auch sagen
das lag zum größten teil daran weil es mich eben auch richtig interessiert hat
ich habe mir damals damals hat man sich auch bücher geholt ja ich habe ich habe
ein riesen fettes
schelm scripting so ein buch was so was so grau gewesen ist
wäsche
das war irgendwie ein 800 seiten buch schelm scripting das habe ich heute noch
das habe ich wirklich gelesen von anfang bis ende und seitdem ich der übelste
bash hacker man finde ich jetzt kann ich ist auch immer
wurscht also das war eigentlich das war das erste buch was ich mir damals zur
ausbildung geholt habe und ich habe wirklich sehr viel gelernt in der zeit
muss mal kurz gucken ob ich das noch finde wie das hieß
besch
die besch kurz und gut ist es nicht ist
script scripting
tja soll ich mal vielleicht nach schelm suchen
schelm hieß dann dieses buch schelm script hier habe ich gekauft
2007 schelm script programmierung schelm script so schöner deutscher titel auch
noch schelm script programmierung genau so ich glaube das ist eine weitere
ausgabe davon meine hier das da das ist es grau genau das da ist es wie viel
seiten 882 seiten schelm scripting leute danach habt ihr ahnung oder ihr habt
aufgegeben
800 seiten schelm scripting da standen die abgedrehtesten sachen drinne
1832 da standen die abgedrehtesten sachen drinne ich wusste danach wie man
arrays in bash macht wie man dictionaries in bash macht wie man options
passt in bash doch leute ich kann mir nicht alles merken aber ihr habt
wahrscheinlich schon im stream gemerkt ich mache ganz gern kleinkram immer noch
in bash also das sind so sachen die habe ich die habe ich alle während der
ausbildung gelernt und das war wirklich gut unterm strich dass ich die ausbildung
gemacht habe dort wo ich sie gemacht habe die ausbildung an sich halt ebenso
aus dem gesichtspunkt es ist jemand da der dir auch mal was beibringt so war
halt scheiße es gab nichts ich saß mit einem anderen azubi zusammen und wir
haben halt uns gegenseitig ab und zu mal ein paar dinger gezeigt und im prinzip
hat man hat man nichts nichts gelernt weil man was beigebracht bekommen hat
sondern man hat was gelernt weil man es entweder lernen musste oder halt
verkackt also verkackt hätte
aber das war wirklich sinnvoll ich meine ich habe so viel gelernt was was
config von netzwerkgeräten angeht was ip tables was firewall sachen angeht was
lindungsadministration angeht was hochverfügbare systeme angeht was
load balancer angeht was proxies angeht also so ziemlich die basis von alledem
was ich jetzt mache was ich jetzt weiß hat sich alles nur entwickelt weil ich
diese drei jahre ausbildung gemacht habe beziehungsweise nicht das kann man so
nicht sagen weil ich diese drei jahre im prinzip selbst wahnsinnig viel zeug
gelernt habe beigebracht hatte ja keiner was ja das fachinformatiker handbuch
hat man eh nur damals gekauft weil man gehofft hat man kann es in der
prüfung verwenden das kann ich auch mr. pari dankeschön für den sub also insofern
das wichtigste ist tatsächlich eigenantrieb zu haben bei der
ausbildung und ich hatte den eigenantrieb wisst ihr wisst ihr warum
also ich hatte ich hatte aus zwei kunden ich hatte aus zwei kunden diesen
eigenantrieb erstens weil die leute dort alle ahnung hatten und ich nicht das war
das erste so oder drei gründe weil die leute alle dort irgendwie ahnung hatten
und ich nicht im endeffekt war klar wenn du dann ausbildung anfängst hast in der
regel erst mal davon keine ahnung das war das erste das zweite war weil mich
das thema unglaublich interessiert hat
generell dass das gesamte lielungsumfeld rechenzentrum umfeld
netzwerktechnik das hat mich wahnsinnig interessiert
dementsprechend habe ich auch viel freiwillig gelernt ich habe abends im
bett gelegen habe best scripting gelesen und solche geschichten ja so und das
dritte war weil ich nicht doof da stehen wollte weil ich was nicht checken das
ist jetzt bestimmt was persönliches aber ich hasse es doof da zu stehen bei
dingern die wo ich denke die müsste ich wissen aber ich weiß sie nicht
mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen besser geworden mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen
besser geworden ich sag mittlerweile bei ganz vielen sachen freiwillig schon nie
gehört keine ahnung aber das hat ein bisschen überwindung gekostet ja also
ich wollte immer nicht doof da stehen war in dem fall nicht das blödeste weil
es hat dazu geführt dass ich mir jeden scheiß angeguckt habe so alles wo ich
festgestellt habe ich keine ahnung von habe ich mir angeguckt und hätte ich
diese drei jahre nicht gemacht wäre ich heute also hätte ich heute nicht den
durchblick in manchen gebieten den ich habe ich bin aber mittlerweile auch so
weit dass ich weiß dass ich von ganz vielen sachen keine ahnung habe muss
man ja auch mal zugeben generell das ganze it thema ist so groß da gibt es so
viele bereiche ohne boden quasi jeder einzelne bereich da kann man gar keine
ahnung von vielen sachen haben aber ich aber ich behaupte mal es gibt durchaus
bereiche da bin ich ganz kompetent mittlerweile und das hätte ich nicht
ohne die ausbildung insofern war das wirklich gut mit der ausbildung dass ich
das war wirklich auch glück dass ich die gekriegt habe leider leider war dieser
laden ziemlich kacke hat sich im nachhinein
rausgestellt habe ich auch mal ein video darüber gemacht kündigung ist raus
warum ich meinen job gekündigt habe genau hier wenn der chef dich verarscht
genau da habe ich ein video darüber gemacht warum ich damals bei diesem
arbeitgeber gekündigt habe und ja die kurzfassung ist die haben angefangen
irgendwer die haben angefangen die leute zu verarschen ja aber wer es genau
wissen will der muss halt das video gucken
ich bin auch im bewerbungsprozess bei meinem traum arbeitgeber habe aber schon
eine zusage von einem anderen unternehmen die wollende rückmeldung
denkst du es ist verwerflich denen zuzusagen und später eventuell wieder zu
kündigen so lange dich an die gesetzlichen
sachen hält es ist überhaupt kein problem weil man muss sich immer fragen ja ich
gebe zu ich habe da auch manchmal so ein bisschen bedenken so nachdem sollte man
das wirklich machen aber ganz im ernst wenn es ein traumjob wirklich ist dann
sieht dann ist es was anderes und zweitens musste dich immer fragen würden
die das umgedreht genauso sehen also würden die beispielsweise sagen
hey wir fühlen uns dem king so verbunden dass wir ihn trotz problem weiter
bei also wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich würden die es umgedreht genauso machen
so also gucken wir mal das video fertig jetzt ich spiele handball seitdem ich
acht jahre alt bin ich habe heute auch noch training und da freue ich mich sehr
drauf mich endlich mal wieder auszupowern
ich glaube ich weiß nicht wie ich das geschafft habe damals ich habe ja früher
auch fünf tage die woche acht tage acht stunden am tag aber 7 7,48 oder so
stunden am tag gearbeitet wenn ich mir überlege du hast quasi montags bis
freitags bist du quasi weg frühmorgens und kommst nachmittags wieder du hast
ja so schon nichts zu machen ich weiß gar nicht weiß bis heute ich
weiß ich ist es mir absolut unbegreiflich wie ich das überhaupt
durchgehalten habe
vielleicht weil ich da auch so na ich war älter als er ich habe meine ausbildung
später erst gemacht ich habe keine ahnung wie ich das durchgehalten hab du
konntest nichts machen was du machen willst ein teil meiner finanziellen
freiheit ist erreicht wenn ich ein eigenes haus habe dass mein wünschen
entspricht haus haus ist generell aktuell nicht so big stonks muss nach
bisschen für studium was lernen und ich habe demnächst mal eine prüfung
schreibe was er studiert auch noch nebenbei hey siri alter habe ich das
gerade richtig verstanden da will es aber echt wissen krasse scheiß moment
recht muss nach bisschen für studium was lernen
alter also sprich also gut ab also ich meine da geht fünf tage die woche
arbeiten nachmittags machte handballtraining und nebenbei studiert
er noch der fac ok der macht halt sonst nix außer arbeiten und lernen ja
irgendwie ich weiß nicht wie ich das früher ausgeholt habe aber der normale
crying halt ich habe demnächst mal eine prüfung schreibe
hey siri schalte die wohnzimmerlampen an
schalte die wohnzimmerlampen an ist es wirklich noch nie passiert du bist du
ich habe letztes jahr im oktober angefangen zu studieren habe mich für
den studium als IT breckleiter entschieden weil es interessiert ein
team zu leiten in der IT branche das denkst du jetzt dass das toll ist das
denkst du jetzt die realität sieht anders aus und das ist auch sehr
zukunftsorientiert das wird in zukunft immer gebraucht das denkt er jetzt
war zwar
was für ein studierger internet nicht hinter projekte IT projekte leiter
he doesn't know er leckt im wahrsten sinne des wortes critical information
so man siehe was war studium sekunde habe ich ja nicht gesehen was
was nur 1,5 jahre es gibt schon die so kurz sind 7000 ein euro ok
so mein ziel das verfolge ich halt mit der motivation hey wenn ich das schaffe
kann ich mehr verdienen ich bin der festen überzeugung dass es keine
bessere
ist die zone gibt als in seiner eigenen bildung das stimmt das stimmt da gebe
ich ihm da gebe ich ihm vollkommen recht ja das ist so aber nur projektleiter zu
machen um mehr zu verdienen ich glaube da gibt es andere möglichkeiten weil man
darf nicht vergessen projektleiter ist absolute abfuck position die du bist
quasi dafür da damit sie dir auf den sack gehen können und du musst anderen
leuten auf den sack gehen also projektleiter ist quasi eines der
undankbarsten und beschissenen sachen die ich mir auch nur im ansatz
vorstellen könnte zu machen ja du wirst damit mehr geld verdienen
ob du danach glücklicher bist habe ich so meine zweifel ich habe mir das letzte
halbe jahr nichts gekauft an kleidung weil der bedarf einfach nicht da war die
sachen passen noch und sehen noch gut aus über wirklich gas geben
zu laut so einfach ist das jetzt auch nicht wie sie ist da wie sie ist im
chat dahin stellt ja da bewerben sich halt irgendwie tausende leute die haben
alle lead code gekreidet
der serie schalte die wohnzimmer lampen aus nur fahrt vorsichtig jetzt kommt
noch der handball grind also da muss man sagen der ist wirklich
beschäftigt der hat keine zeit für was anderes
der geht arbeiten er geht studieren er geht abends einmal spielen da ist vorbei
gut aber muss sagen handball ist ja quasi bestimmt auch so ein bisschen der
fun factor für ihn dabei und es ist wirklich wichtig ich kann es nicht oft
genug sagen seit ich das mache fühle ich mich wirklich deutlich agiler
bewegung ohne mist leute hätte ich mir das selbst vor fünf bis zehn jahren
erzählt hätte ich gesagt max keck weit willst du mich verarschen
nein ist wirklich so und sei es nur eine halbe stunde in einer stunde eine halbe
stunde ist ist sicherlich besser aber alles ist besser als nur vorm rechner
sitzen und sich gar nicht bewegen und das blöde ist umso schlecht das einem dann
geht weil man rückenschmerzen hat kopfschmerz um so weniger möchte man
sich bewegen und denkt sich boah ich muss mich weiter schonen weil mir geht
es ja so schlecht stimmt aber überhaupt nicht man muss anfangen sich zu bewegen
dann wird es besser
die komme ich auf 48 fps für den stream weil ich dann einen besseren
kompromiss aus auflösung bitrate und flüssige wiedergabe habe
letztendlich ist es aber wahrscheinlich egal ich könnte auch mein desktop
stream auf 60 fps würde wahrscheinlich die sache auch nicht flüssiger aussehen
lassen geschweige denn schlechter ja aber 48 fps naja gut jedes auge 24 fps
kommt man auf 48
ja und übrigens eine sache die auch wichtig ist ist ausschlafen weil ich bin
ja früher 5 45 aufgestanden leute ich konnte euch überhaupt ihr könnt euch
überhaupt nicht vorstellen und ich ich habe es damals auch nicht realisiert wie
im halbschlaf ich eigentlich den ganzen tag gewesen bin
ich war morgens müde ich war auf der arbeit müde ich war mittags müde ich war
müde als ich heimgekommen ich war immer müde ganzen tag seit seit homeoffice
möglich ist und seit ich ein bisschen länger penne und es macht halt einen
unterschied leute 5 45 versus 7 oder versus 7 30 ist einfach komplett andere
welt die eineinhalb die eine bis eineinhalb stunden macht unglaublich
viel aus
ihr seid einfach viel wache und fitter und besser ja auch in dem was ihr macht
level cap schiebe ne da hat nichts neues hau rein
bäme exzellent aus das tos musik tos
tos tos konsumgüter nicht so wichtig wie soziale erlebnisse aber dicken bmw
haben erinnerungen aber sehe ich auch so ich kaufe mir auch so gut wie nie was
aber wenn dann halt auf was ordentliches so die musik dabei
tausend euro geldanlage so richtig so ist richtig stonks
massive stonks keine miete doch der bezahlt bestimmt ein bisschen was
der bezahlt der bezahlt bestimmt ein bisschen was an ihm oder gibt er
garantiert ab was war es von mir hier gibt es noch das video zum fach
informatiker hier gibt es noch andere videos und nicht vergessen die glocke
zu aktivieren vielleicht wurde auch im bmw genau also ich
mein man hat von seinem job jetzt ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig gesehen
außer dass er html copy pastet aber ok boss im rathaus das verdient ein
beamter in der das muss man sich angucken der boss im rathaus exzellent
senior copy paste engineer hast du schon die folge mit dem ja die folge mit dem
fach informatiker gesehen mit dem IT projektleiter gesehen mit dem
software entwickler gesehen mit dem start-up kunder gesehen wir haben
eigentlich alle die die irgendwie interessant für mich sind schon gesehen
chat seid ihr brain afk oder so das haben wir doch vor einer minute geguckt
die neue folge mit dem e-commerce tut ok das einzige was du antworten kannst ist
darauf jetzt ich bin erst seit 30 sekunden da das ok das lasse ich gelten
der tribun und da geschehen 33 monate hyper subscription nice na dann ok dann
geht das geht durch ja ok das ist lasse ich gelten so was haben hier real nicht
folger sagen real talk reale ihr sind komplizierte zollanmeldung oh nee alter
mit dem zoll hatte ich auch schon öfters meinen spaß am besten ist das wo der
e-book der express versandt irgendwie zwei wochen in leipzig gelegen hat und ich
mit der wo mich wo mich einer angerufen hat vom zoll in leipzig und ich habe die
gefragt was war das irgendwie so was muss ich in dem und dem fall denn jetzt
eigentlich machen oder oder ich weiß ich habe sie was total naheliegendes
gefragt oder hat sie gesagt hat sie darauf geantwortet das dürfen sie mich
jetzt aber nicht fragen wo ich mir auch gedacht hat warum ruft die mich denn an
genau ich weiß wieder was das war die hat mich angerufen hat gesagt
irgendwelche zoll geschichten müssen auch ausgefüllt werden und da habe ich
sie gefragt ja was ist denn mit dem was ich vor zwei tagen ausgefüllt habe ich
habe doch den kampf von vor zwei tagen schon ausgefüllt und zu ihnen geschickt
oder meint sie was damit ist das dürfen sie mich jetzt aber nicht fragen
wie jetzt also ich das noch mal ausfüllen und was die letzten zwei tage
passiert das dürfen sie mich aber nicht fragen jetzt zumindest ich habe was
bestellt in usa per express und ich habe dhl dafür bezahlt dass sie die zoll
abfertigung für mich machen hat 20 euro extra gekostet und was ist im endeffekt
passiert es ist hängen geblieben in zoll im leib zoll in leipzig am
flughafen in einem dhl zentrum und ich sollte auf einmal wieder irgendwas
ausfüllen und die haben es einfach nicht hinbekommen
sie haben es nicht hinbekommen ich habe dann paar mal hin und her ich habe was
ausgefüllt und gemacht sie haben es nicht hinbekommen
wisst ihr was das einzige war was funktioniert hat ich habe am
hersteller ich habe den hersteller angeschrieben und die man die der
hersteller meinte ja das kann sein dass die ein bisschen für brauchen und als
es irgendwie nach ja genau so was wie gesagt ich habe dhl gesagt die sollen
sich um die zoll abfertigung kümmern so und danach habe ich dem anbieter noch
mal geschrieben habe gesagt also ich warte da jetzt irgendwie schon eineinhalb
wochen drauf ich habe das per express bestellt weil ich das halbwegs schnell
brauche ich weiß dass sie da nichts für können aber wenn ich das innerhalb dann
jetzt nicht bekomme dann ist es zu spät dann werde ich quasi nicht annehmen das
habe ich dem anbieter geschickt und darauf hat sich der anbieter instant
gemeldet hat gesagt ok sie werden dort mal anrufen
dann hat der anbieter dort angerufen und irgendwie einen tag später ist das
paket freigegeben worden also ganz ganz abartig so beim zoll selbst war ich schon
paar mal lustigerweise ihr wisst ja ich bin ein alter china china chinesen
aliexpress besteller ich musste noch nicht einmal für china zeug zum zoll
aber ich musste so gut wie jedes mal für sachen aus den usa zum zoll deswegen
bestelle ich wenn sich nicht irgendwie anders regeln lässt nichts mehr aus den
usa ich glaube die amis kriegen das mit den zoll dokumenten einfach nicht
gescheit hin oder aber die chinesen faken das so gut dass sie irgendwas
draufschreiben was realistisch aussieht obwohl es das gar nicht ist das kann das
weiß ich nicht keine ahnung aber ich glaube die chinesen kriegen es einfach
besser hin als die amis also sieht er zum fürchten aus hier
haferlängerung und perücken bis zu 50 prozent rabatt ja die muss ich mir bei
aliexpress kaufen haferlängerung ganz klar
die militärausrüstung kann sie auch bei aliexpress kaufen
aber es ein schrott die seite sieht halt jetzt wirklich nach scam aus muss man
halt sagen jemand der noch nie der noch nie bei aliexpress bestellt hat und die
seite aufmacht der denkt doch das ist gemm oder diese seite sieht einfach
brutals nach scam aus aber ist es nicht wenn man beispielsweise mal wieder neue
runde esp 32 brauche es aliexpress wahrscheinlich immer noch das beste
was hat denn der hat mehr flash glaube ich es ist überhaupt kein scam
ich habe nie ich wurde nie gescampt bei aliexpress das einzige mal wo ich
eventuell gescampt wurde anbieter mich eventuell versucht hat zu scammen ist wo
die die haben eine tracking link geschickt und haben gesagt er kommt
mal an und irgendwie zwei wochen später stand es auf dem tracking link immer
noch als nicht losgeschickt da habe ich den anbieter angeschrieben sie haben
den gleichen tracking link noch mal geschickt nicht elektronik ja sowas
bestelle ich ja auch nicht bei aliexpress und dann hat der anbieter
die mit den gleichen tracking link noch mal geschickt hat gesagt sie haben
jetzt neu losgeschickt aber es war der gleiche tracking link und daraufhin bin
ich zu diesem konflikt lösungs portal in aliexpress gegangen habe das
eingesteht habe das eingereicht als konflikt lösungs fall und es ist
folgendes passiert aliexpress hat den anbieter angeschrieben
der anbieter hat mir den gleichen tracking link noch mal geschickt und
aliexpress hat mir geantwortet ja sind sie jetzt mit der antwort zufrieden und
ich habe einfach einen tag nicht reagiert und darauf haben sie gesagt ok
sie haben nicht reagiert sie sind anscheinend nicht zufrieden es gibt das
geld zurück also einfacher ging es nicht ich
wusste nichts machen ob das geld wieder gekriegt bei paypal wo ich mal bei
scamfox bestellt habe da wollten die dass ich foto schicke vom gebrochenen
klasse ich habe ich habe mal bei bei so einer komischen billigseite ein rack
bestellt mit einer klasse tue und das klasse war kaputt nach der lieferung oder
im im paket schon dass ich foto schicke oder hat die seite gesagt so ah sie
wissen nicht genau ob ich das nicht vielleicht kaputt gemacht haben und
sonst wie und ein tag bevor dieses ultimatum dann von paypal abgelaufen ist
hat mich einer angerufen von diesem shop alter was ein hin und her da bestelle
ich nie wieder was und den paypal käufer schutz kann es in der richtung
auch vergessen da war der aliexpress käufer schutz
deutlich besser wurdest du bei irgendwelchen kickstarter projekten
gescampt ja wurde ich ich wurde einmal gescampt bei einer selbst reinigen den
hose
ja die haben ich gescampt ihr werdet jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen man
wie kann man so was glauben aber das klang klang nicht schlecht ja also bei
einer selbst reinigen hose wurde gescampt warum ist das überhaupt immer noch ab
auf kickstarter die haben nicht einen ausgeliefert die haben einfach komplett
gescampt letztes update 2018 also da wurde ich wo man sich so was kauft weil ich
das cool fand dass eine hose nicht dreckig werden kann und ich habe gleich
das paket geholt mit t-shirt und so dabei hose und t-shirt
also es gab ein paket mit mit hose und t-shirt ich habe irgendwie keine ahnung
was war das 200 dollar oder so wurde ich wurde ich gescampt so da wurde ich
gescampt und eine sache wo man nicht 100 prozentig von scam reden kann aber zu
99 prozent hier wurde ich auch gescampt da habe ich auch gebacked irgendwie auch
auch irgendwas so 150 200 euro
das das wird auch nie rauskommen
guck mal das ist seit zehn jahren in entwicklung und das einzige was sie
immer noch hochladen sind konzeptzeichnungen das ist einfach so so
verkackt worden das projekt mal gucken ob es news gab in letzter zeile
es gibt einfach nix es gibt konzeptbilder
guckt euch das an das ist ein game was zehn jahre in entwicklung ist einer
ok das ist ein altes video das ist ein altes video vergesst ja die zeigen
heute immer noch konzeptzeichnung und irgendwelche leute meine gütte die haben
über zwei millionen kickstarter gesammelt aber haben wohl angeblich auch
noch weitere investitionen gehabt ich meine zwei millionen ist bei weitem nicht
genug um ein umfangreiches mmo zu entwickeln mit einem team und allem dabei
aber sie hatten ja wohl auch noch mehr investitionen aber letztendlich dass das
da jemals was rauskommt glaube ich nicht es gibt aber immer noch extrem viele
krass verplenete fanboys gerade auf reddit in diesem subreddit zu kamelot
und schenkt leute unglaublich die die fanboyen darum als als wer das spiel
zwei wochen vor release dabei wird es nie erscheinen
was macht eigentlich mein meine meine follower wie viele follower wie ist die
follower entwickt
was ist das ist normal ja wisst ihr wisst ihr warum ich nachgeguckt habe weil
ich habe gerade links bei mir auf monitor ich habe den chat ich habe die chat
vorschau offen und da habe ich gesehen 23 952 da habe ich mir gedacht das aber
ganz schön viel ich kann mich noch daran erinnern
irgendwie was mit 20 vorne und das ist bestimmt anzeige back haben das andere
auch was hat denn der loss zum beispiel heute ok nice gg eats habe ich
irgendwas vergessen wurden wir irgendwie von irgendjemanden großem gehostet oder
so ich habe nichts mitbekommen
ne oder wartet mal ich muss mal kurz gucken was ist passiert filter
beim subscribt subscription
war nix ich habe keine ahnung wahrscheinlich irgendwelche genau die
zielgruppe für mein gelaber und für programmier stream ja ich glaube auch
ich glaube ins geheim gucken sich die ganzen würden sich die ganzen montaner
pleck zuschauer gerne programmier streaks angucken ok dann ist es irgendeine
komische back den ich nicht näher nachvollziehen kann
so also toll aktiv digger genau
twitch tracker
ja oder ist es nicht so also was macht der zoll simon österreicher veranstaltet
datorniere und hat einen dartshop in neuse bei augsburg kürzlich hat er neue
taschen für daten entwickel der mobile apps ok ok ich gebe zu cringe cringe
witz im internet bestellt für 350 euro er hat nur eine kleinigkeit also der zoll
dass die darts täschchen dann endlich beim zoll hier vorlagen da habe ich dann
ein brief bekommen ja die sind da du musst aber eine internet zollanmeldung
noch abgeben damit du die holen kannst dann habe ich mir die angeschaut und da
haben wir gedacht ok sauber stellt euch mal vor 720p in 2022
ich glaube es gibt kein der das kann herr österreicher was gibt es denn dazu
lachen ab einem wahren wert von 150 euro muss eine iza abgegeben werden also die
internet das das weiß ich noch leute als ich mein dream screen bestellt hab das
ist so aus den usa das ist so ein ambi light was du dir hinter den fernseh
kleben kannst ja sieht sieht so aus das habe ich bestellt das musste ich auch
beim zoll abholen das hat irgendwie auch 200 euro oder so gekostet da musste ich
mit dem auch ausfüllen meine güte ich habe dem gezeigt was das ist und dann
meinte der typ vom zoll ok das ist ein fernseh das ist ein tv gerät meinte er
zu mir oder es ist ein fernsehgerät nein das ist kein fernsehgerät die kiste ist
zehn mal zehn zentimeter das kann doch kein fernseh sein das ist was was du
hinter den fernseh klebst das ist eine beleuchtung beleuchtung für den
fernseh das ist kein fernseh ja dann muss da aus einer irgendwie 50 seitigen liste
raussuchen welche kategorie das passt und so was er meinte ernsthaft das ist
ein fernseh
die scheiße taugt das was ja das ist richtig gut das problem ist nur
dreamscreen ist pleite oder ist gibt es nicht mehr es gibt aber alternativ
produkte die wohl auch ganz gut sind aber ich kann ihr nichts empfehlen weil ich
keins im einsatz habe
beantwortet werden wie art des grenzüberschreitenden aktiven
beförderungs mittels es war ein follower bot wirklich mich hat jemand gebotet
ernsthaft hat immer ein geld dafür ausgegeben mich zu botten leist
keckel wagen schiff wagen flugzeug ok wie zur hölle soll ich jetzt wissen ob
das mit dem schiff man kann es davon abgesehen stellt euch mal vor ihr
bestellt was aus china was weiß ich wie das hergekommen ist wo soll ich das
wissen über die grenze gekommen ist na dann die hier wenigstens wie lautet das
kennzeichen des beförderungs mittels bei der ankunft
kennzeichen vom schiff oder was soll man das wissen handelt es sich bei den
dataschen um eine aktive veredelung im it verfahren soll lagerverfahren im it
verfahren als versandschein genutzt österreicher nicht irgendwas eingeben
fragen sie besser beim zoll noch mal nach am anfang war auch ein bisschen
grantige ja es fängt schon mal an die erste frage schon falsch die zweite
sauber dann mir gedacht ja super da hatte wahrscheinlich so netten typ dran wie ich
im zoll der mir erzählen wollte ich hätte angeblich in fernsehen bestellt
gut dann rat ich halt was anderes herr österreicher konzentrieren sie sich geht
es um die überführung von wahren in den zoll rechtlich freien verkehr mit
gleichzeitiger wiederversendung im rahmen des wahrenverkehrs zwischenteilen
des tolles aber zum glück eine ausfüllhilfe und als ich die aufgemacht
habe da musste ich so lachen warum die 24-seitige ausfüllhilfe vom zoll erklärt
doch alles ganz übersichtlich und wer die zollanmeldung nicht hinkriegt so die
empfehlung der generalzolldirektion kann ja entsprechende kurse führt das ist ja
wenn du in irgendeinem hardware shop arbeitest und täglich 5000 pakete aus
den usa oder china bestellt ja dann würde ich auch so ein kurs machen aber
doch nicht irgendein typ der padat pfeile in china bestellt hat man
zoll angelegenheiten belegen ja klar
geil nach fünf telefonaten und drei emails mit dem zoll ist das ist das eine
spezielle datarm fixierung dass er besser genauer zielen kann durfte er
sein paket endlich abholen war doch gar nicht so schwer als studierter
wirtschaftsjurist hast du wahrscheinlich gute chancen diese zoll erklärung
richtig auszufüllen ich habe es leider nicht geschafft ich habe ich glaube
nicht mal der zoll kann das richtig ausfüllen
nur psychologie studiert mein fehl naja herr österreicher jetzt wissen sie ja
was man machen muss mit der internet zollanmeldung
oh man ja also da wundert mich nix wir haben ja teilweise so überbohrende
bürokratische hürden da muss man doch nicht wundern dass innovation da auf der
strecke bleibt
habt soll im großhandel gemacht wenn es dann usw geht wird es richtig los
na gut bei usw ist wahrscheinlich auch die sache mit sind da lithium akkus
drinnen und sowas weil lithium darfst ja theoretisch auch nicht so ohne weiteres
im flugzeug transportieren und sowas ist dann gibt es immer zig verschiedene
bestimmungen für
wahrscheinlich wissen sie noch nicht mal selbst wie man das richtig aus aus
fällt kennst du schon das video von big boss zu
battlefield 2042 ne luftanze hat er text gebannt das habe ich gelesen das habe
ich gelesen beheise und die heise forums leute waren wieder am starten haben
gesagt ich lasse trotzdem drinnen bäm jetzt zeige ich stehen
ist halt schön wenn du dann im flugzeug setzt beziehungsweise aufgerufen wirst
so nach dem motto hier kommen sie mal da vorbei mit ihrem pack mit ihrem
gepäck gibt es probleme oder sitzt im flugzeug und sagen wir konnten leider
den koffer nicht transportieren aber unerlaubte sachen drin
du musst eine usw anmelden also wenn du als privater typ im flugzeug
sitzend usw fliegen willst auf jeden fall weil du darfst keine lithium
batterien ins gepäck packen oder was was sagt die usw für zu hause muss man
mittlerweile auch beim was warum nee
warum sollte man das machen müssen die usw hat doch überhaupt keine keine
auswirkung so wirklich du musst du musst ja du musst eine ladestation anmelden
fürs elektroauto zum beispiel wenn sie mehr als elf kilowatt leistung hat aber
ich meine keine hatten elf kilowatt über elf kilowatt usw
ist neu egal mache ich trotzdem nicht
das ist auch was das müssen wir probieren ich muss meine usw wieder
irgendwie in gang kriegen weil ich habe gelesen dass meine cyber
power usw angeblich hotswap fähige batterien hat und wie kann es sein dass
bei einer usw die hotswap fähige batterien hat bei einem defekt der
batterie die gesamte usw ausgeht trotz dem dass der netzstrom noch da ist das
ergibt doch keinen sinn vielleicht muss ich mal firmware update machen und mal
in den settings ein bisschen rumspielen bevor ich mir eine neue usw kaufe weil
es ergibt doch keinen sinn oder leute wenn ihr eine hotswap fähige usw habt
warum sollte die usw komplett ausgehen obwohl der strom noch da ist wenn die
wenn der akku verreckt dass die eine warnung schickt ok aber ganz ausgehen ist
ja das gegenteil von dem was man mit der usw erreichen will
mal firmware update machen gibt es firmware updates dafür segon ich gucke
mal kurz aufs firmware update gibt 600 ol ol ol 600 auch was weiß ich wie mein
usw heißt ist sie das moment gibt es gibt es firmware updates die war über
50 prozent ausgelastet nie im leben
req wo ist hier req bauweise req seht ihr irgendwas req mount
und alle meine sieht es so aus wie das hier aber ist sie nicht doch doch das
ist die so die ist nämlich hotswap fähig
jetzt hotswap fähige batterien und gibt es firmware updates dafür
software
alter was gibt's mit der power panel in chinesisch
ok ich sehe ich muss power ich muss power panel business edition für linux installieren
ich hänge da nachher mal ein raspberry pi dran und gucke ob man etwas sinnvolles
damit einstellen kann gibt es da firmware updates für eine
überscheinung das macht man bestimmt da drüber muss man nachher ausprobieren
das eine line interactive oder das eine line interactive online usw ist für mich viel
zu overkillen und selbst online usw haben ja meistens so
einen bypass dafür wenn die batterie verreckt kannst du dann zwar konfigurieren aber du
willst halt eigentlich so gut wie nie dass es ausfällt weil die batterie verreckt außerdem
haben die manchmal dann sogar zwei batterien das ist relativ beziehungsweise hotswap fähig
auf jeden fall ist also der unterschied zwischen der online und allein interactive ist ja dass
die online usw immer die die kisten dahinter versorgt aus der batterie und die line interactive
nur umschaltet auf die batterie wenn der strom ausgeht das heißt eine line interactive sollte
eigentlich prinzipiell nie ausgehen wenn die batterie verreckt oder strom noch da ist aber
war in dem fall so aber trotzdem darf darf nicht sein
ah exquisite diese dien also diene 6 20401 oder eben vdr ok es gibt auch oder oder vde 0 5 5 8
binne strich 510 obviously war uns das allen bekannt im vorfeld ich hoffe ihr wusste das chat wenn
ich dann wird es kritisch kennt man ja hoffe ich auch so was kann man sonst noch angucken
worst kill streaks in every call of duty naja gut der worst kill streak ist in in black ops 1 ok in
black ops 1 kann ich euch sagen was der worst kill streak war in black ops 1 waren das diese
komischen fake predator raketen da die mit diesem raketenwerfer die niemand die jemand
niemand gespielt hat die man glaube ich sogar bekommen hatten über den care package unsinnig
sentry gun ja sentry gun war useless velkeri rockets genau useless remote sentry useless
escort schon so so scheiße war die doch gar nicht ghost weiß ich gar nicht was das gab
advanced warfare remote turret ok rolling thunder das war auch in black ops 1 schon nicht gut
moment molotov cocktail war ein kill streak so jetzt wissen wir bescheid was die worst kill
streaks sind ohne das video uns angeguckt zu haben haben wir sonst noch strange strangest
computer design 2010 alles klar zeit mal her also was ganz abgedreht war manche alien
wer gehäuse die science wo ich mich da schon immer gefragt hat warum becoming good enough ok
weiter so let's look at them oder solche dinge da ja bunch of computers from the 20 teens that
stand out for their weirdness in regards to overall look usability and specifications alike
starting with the jack pc by chip pc technologies moment das ist eine steckdose kicking off the decade
in 2010 was a thin client computer with a twist die idee finde ich gar nicht mal so doof instead
of connecting a little box to the wall why not put the little box in the wall precisely what
eigentlich finde ich die idee gar nicht gar nicht übel die sache ist halt die was kann da
schon drin gewesen sein but it's a thin client so most data was stored on the connected server
the second gen apple mac pro der aschenbecher ja an den kann ich mich auch noch erinnern
this 2013 refresh of the mac pro raised many an eyebrow compared to the relatively utilitarian
design of the 2006 model it was replacing affectionately no dieser mülleimer das das
also das design das konnte ich auch nichts abgewinnen trash can mac it packed everything
dachte erst immer an aschenbecher aber ja wahrscheinlich eher wie mülleimer
aktueller top rechner kostet ich mittlerweile auch schon die hälfte wie gesagt 4 bis 5000
euro für einen richtig top aktuellen high end rechner mit 40 90
warum müssen die auch den größten crap apple nachmachen ich mein was zum teufel ist
das denn das das sieht aus wie wie wie eine hertplatte mit gasbrenner seem to copy apple
homework each of which i might have included in their own section of this video but i do
also in kämpchen von the trash cans to the alien war 51 irgendwie wusste ich dass da
in allen wer gehäuse treine vorkommen muss dell subsidiary alien ware made plenty of
brightly colored area 51 pcs in the 2000s but it was the 2014 model that really embraced
its extraterrestrial theme the so-called triad design area 51 featured a spaceship inspired
triangular case that not only looked nuts but provided plenty of room inside room for
up to three gpus five hard drives and nine separate rgb lighting zones wichtig wichtig
nicht die drei grafikkarten sind wichtig nein neun separate rgb belichtungs einhalten
zonen das ist wichtig where controlled for maximum gamer aesthetic the idea was the angled
design meant users could reach io more easily and that proper airflow could be maintained
even if the case was pushed against the wall but really it's because it looked neat the
video technology volta v claiming to be the first commercially produced handcrafted wooden
computer the volta v understandably made headlines in 2017 built ja irgendjemand hat ein computer
in den holz in ein schrank eingebaut in eine schublade eingebaut und weiter headlines in
2017 built by studio technology und weiter the v featured a solid das kann jeder daheim
der handwerklich geschickt ist auch machen warum man es machen sollte keine ahnung aber können
können können ja walnut case an understated look compared to the garish rgb glass boxes out
there but that hardwood made it rather costly compared to traditional rigs ranging from two
to three and a half thousand dollar mister noch nicht mal hier richtig schön aufeinander actually
got to cover a review unit on lgr back then and it was a pleasure to use and smelled great
unfortunately cdo has since gone out of the richt die auch immer an eurer hardware ja but i'm glad
they were able to leave a well varnished mark before bowing out das sieht auch aus wie selbst
gemacht leute das sieht einfach aus wie selbst gebaut
mark before bowing out the machines mini er 1402 small form factor pcs had a bit of a moment in
the early 2010s but the mini e took a different path than most instead of a simple black box
he machines made a diamond shaped case they described as looking more like modern art
than computer it measured just seven inches across and weighed about nine pounds small enough to
mount onto a visa plate behind a monitor or tv of course it's also worth noting that this wasn't
the super cheap e machines of old but rather that's the opposite billig aus ja a sir who
purchased e machines parent company gateway in 2007 still not too shabby for 299 dollars the
a sir predator 21 x a sir in 2017 had no chill the predator 21 x was not only the best thing
alter also mobil ist damit nicht wirklich was was wiegt das 6 kilo oder was first curved screen
laptop but this 19 pound beast 8,5 kilo alter 8,5 kilo und was hat es für akkulaufzeit 15
minuten akkulaufzeit miners had lost their minds and it was glorious a 4.1 gigahertz core i7 64
gigabytes of ram dual g-force gtx 1080s five drive slots to power supplies five cooling
for speakers to subwoofers a mechanical keyboard a trackpad that flips over to a numpad a battery
lasting less than an hour when gaming and a nine thousand dollar price tag for all the ridiculous
everything a sir managed to sell the entire limited run meaning there are 300 these monsters lying
around somewhere all around the globe and that makes me smile the fujitsu ch 702 floral kiss in
2012 fujitsu japan introduced the floral kiss series a brand of quote personal computers for
women available an elegant white luxury brown and feminine pink computer laptops aimed to create a
pc that women would find appealing as such it came with a pearl power button synthetic diamonds
embedded into the keyboard the cables the mouse the mouse is that the mouse btf verbildert mit
somers arbeiten mann guckt euch die maus an puck shaped mouse along with built-in apps like scrap
booking a daily horoscope and a diary with integrated social media posting it was even designed so that
users could open it without the risk of damaging their nails the general public reacted about as
well as you may imagine the hulet packard omen x 900 compared by some to a borg cube or transformers
all spark the liquid cooled omen x was a wild departure from your typical boring hp pavilion
the black and red cube featured four hot swappable hard drive bay bei dem letzten kratze von ausgehen
wahrscheinlich keine frauen an der entwicklung beteiligt gewesen dann wäre sowas nicht rausgekommen
optical drive bay and hardware specs that put it well into gaming pc territory though it was an
absolute space hog measuring roughly 20 and a quarter by 20 by 16 inches double the width of a
regular pc case it also cost between 1800 and 2600 dollars several hundred dollars more than
competing systems of its capabilities a hard sell unless you really love cubes rotated 45 degrees
the asus rog gx 700 asus is no stranger to portable desktop
oft in packing their rog series laptops was ein fettes ding aber asus hat da eh so ein
bisschen in dachschaden asus hat ja auch monitore mit lüftung und hatte ja auch dieses gaming
smartphone wurde den lüfter dran klippen konntest dass es nicht überhitzt components
that push the limits of portability but the gx 700 was ding claiming to be the first water
cooled laptop warum muss der laptop wasser gekühlt sein der fack man reveal in late 2015
ja das sieht wirklich aus wie ein waffeleisen das stimmt es ist nicht nur ein dicken best of
a machine on its own but that huge growth around back docks to the system and connects it to
an array of copper pipes inside the laptop resulting in a claimed performance boost of
forty eight percent to the cpu and forty three percent to the gpu and a total weight of eighteen
and a half pounds super cool super impractical cyber powers trinity extreme for the most part
systems builder cyber power pops their pc's into moment die das ist aber cyber power die
nichts mit dem usv hersteller zu tun haben what the fuck das sieht aus wie eine drone von oben
relatively standard shaped towers but that restraint was tossed out the window with the trinity
extreme in 2015 assembled in conjunction with deep cool the trinity separated its components
into three different blades in theory allowing for better airflow and cooling one blade holding
the gpu and ssd's another for the power supply and three three and a half inch hard drives and the
last one holding the itx motherboard and liquid cooling system quite the intriguing layout with
the unavoidable trade-off of taking up swathes of desk space at eighteen and a half inches wide
the zotac zbox oh one five two oh toller toller produktname oder primarily ließ sich wie der
handyde vorwahl in other components zotac unveiled a range of zbox mini pc das sieht aus
wie ein voice assistant das das könnte irgendeine alexa box sein heute in 2011 but it's the zero one
five two zero model that caught the most headlines on its arrival in 2014 bringing to mind the fail nexus q by google the spherical zbox was quite the standout design compared to other small form factor pc's and even compared to zotac's other offerings like their relatively bland looking steam machine
launched alongside it of course it wasn't a perfect orb the base of it was actually cube shaped
and the components but i have to say that is actually in design what i mean i wouldn't buy it
what appeals to me in a certain way because at least the design looks like it belongs that way
and not as if we just took a turned off case and put it in a standard mainboard and cut out connections
rausgekattet das designer hat irgendwie was ich meine ich würde es mir nicht kaufen aber es ist okay
können ich mir durchaus vorstellen
but hey there's just something about little round pc's that grabs attention and finally razors project valerie dual screen laptops
ach das war das notebook mit dem ausklappbaren display da erinnere ich mich noch dran
ich erinnere mich das kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern irgendjemand hat es geklaut
an das kann ich mich noch dran erinnern an das thing was wir das vorgestellt haben
ja das wäre es tatsächlich aber es ist ähnlich wie die leute die früher zeitungen in der bahn gelesen
haben die die haben sich auch immer wahnsinnig breit gemacht damit wobei du hattest auch manchmal so
die zeitungs falter die dann irgendwie gefühlt fünf minuten mit dem knicken ihrer zeitung
beschäftigt waren und alle zehn sekunden umgefaltet haben aber zeitung ist halt so was von
boomer technologie man sieht kaum noch leute mit zeitungen in der bahn das ist quasi wie
ausgestorben ist ja unsinnig warum warum sollte man warum sollte man auch kommen eigene videos
von mir die muss ich anklicken für für view time view time beste ich habe hunger leute was
ist das zehn nützliche shortcuts für computerprofis zwischen tabs wechseln pc sperren ordner erstellen
adressleister auswählen bildschirm anpassen bildschirm aufteilen ich glaube dass wir sind
nicht experte genug für der logitech gcloud gaming hand hält ist kompletter müll sehe ich genauso
ist es auch habe ich glaube ich habe sogar kommentiert irgendwo was unter das video so
nach dem motto coole konkurrenz für stadia kappa es ist kein eigener streaming service aber es hat
ich einfach angeboten weil stadia mittlerweile den stecker gezogen bekommt bekommt das video
zum staubfilter fach ja ihr habt recht gibt es ja auch noch aha ok dann lassen wir uns
noch mal erzählen warum er das kacke findet macht echt gute videos guck fast jedes video
von ihm gibt es zwar nicht so oft welche aber wenn es welche gibt guck ich eigentlich fast
alle auf geht's dass das sound stimmt machen um mich auf mein neues studio zu konzentrieren
damit das in ruhe aufbauen kann und dann sehe ich etwas so unfassbar dämliches und es ist
der logitech logis ist das logitech gcloud gaming hand hält logitech bringt einen eigenen
handheld raus und vor allem leute auf twitter leute ich kann es nicht verstehen ja ich habe
es ja auch gesehen die ankündigung die ganzen leute auf twitter wie sie drauf geantwortet
haben sie nach dem motto logitech ihr habt da was ganz tolles neues oder irgendwie diese
die die also die leute machen schreiben das ja nicht auf die machen dieses ei emoji da
immer drunter hier dieses das da guck ja so wo man sich dann halt denkt warum wer für
wen soll das sein oder kommen die ganzen technisch absolut planlosen influencer dudes an und
schreiben dann auch noch irgendwas drunter so nach dem motto da habe ich jetzt schon
immer drauf gewartet gehen auf die ankündigung regelrecht ab ich verstehe nicht warum den
ersten blick gar nicht begreifen was für eine unsagbar dumme idee dieser das denke
ich auch denn es ist weder eine konkurrenz wie switch noch für das dem deck noch für
irgendein anderes gerät weil es so einzigartig nutzlos ist dass es kein gerät gibt das genauso
nutzlos ist um es vergleichen zu können ok genug aufgebaut schauen wir uns mal diese
wundervolle ansammlung an unnötigen komponenten genauer an also logitech hat ihren einen hand
hält vorgestellt den logitech gcloud gaming hand hält der aber übrigens der aber übrigens
nicht mobil funktioniert weil das ding hat kein lte und kein nix drinnen das ding funktioniert
nur wifi und dementsprechend ja eigentlich auch nur daheim oder irgendwo wo es wifi gibt
aber naja also wo sollen wir ein ordentliches wifi haben wir nicht daheim also es ist es
ist einfach komplett eine eine ansammlung an unsinnigen sachen also ich habe mich von
anfang angefragt für wen soll das sein in der präsentation haben sie das gerät fast
immer so bezeichnet logitech gcloud gaming hand hält das gaming hand hält ist der untertitel
und wird gar nicht den manager dude hat seinem chef das gepitzt das ding und er hat so geil
das machen wir oder dass sie sich über ihren eigenen kram gedanken gemacht haben irgendwann
nicht mehr genannt da er nur dazu dient den leuten einzuhämmern was das für ein teil
überhaupt ist also steam das steam deck das verstehe ich ja noch das kann ich ich kann
mir ausmalen warum jemand ein steam deck hat du kannst du kannst als single player spiele
überall spielen beziehungsweise unabhängig von deiner netzwerkverbindung ok verstehe
ich ja ich brauche es nicht aber ich verstehe es aber das das verstehe ich nenne es ab jetzt
nur das logitech g weil das sonst super nervig wird also das logitech g ist ein android basiertes
gerät mit dem fokus auf cloud services wie geforce now und xbox game pass ebenso habt
ihr zugriff auf die musik und damit auch apps wie netflix youtube et cetera verbaut ist
ein snapdragon 720 g chip wie viel leistung hat er nun es ist der mittelklasse snapdragon
von vor zwei jahren von daher ist er jetzt bereits veraltet ich nutze das poco f3 als
handy das besitzt ein snapdragon 870 und kostete damals vor etwas hat jemals schon was jemals
jemals schon was von einem poco s3 gehört ich kenne mich bei android handys auch nicht aus
muss ich ehrlich sagen china chinesen chinesen zeug ok die machen ja ganz sinnvolle sachen
schaumi die machen ja sinnvolle sachen allerdings muss man sagen es ist ja auch so ein zusammenschluss
von mehreren herstellern 300 euro für mich persönlich kommt mir kein gerät mit weniger
leistung ins haus weil ich zum ersten mal zufrieden mit der leistung eines android handys bin ich bin
halt komplett was android handys angeht weil ich habe seit jahren ein iphone weil ich das umsonst
bekomme mein handy nicht rumzuckt ruckelt oder sonstige macken hat weil das betriebssystem an
sich schon gefühlt die halbe leistung frisst für 300 euro hatte es damals gut leistung und ist für
mich der standard geworden verrückt wäre es da wenn ein gerät weniger leistung bietet und dann
dabei mehr kosten würde genau das haben wir hier denn das durch die wird für 350 auf gerade dass
man so was wie rocket league sieht gerade games wie rocket league wo es wirklich um input leg
precisest movement und ja keine keine gelege und geruckele drauf ankommt ist auf dem ding halt
komplett deplatziert das haben wir hier denn das durch die wird für 350 dollar auf den mark kommen
das sind alle schon mal sachen die mir ganz persönlich reichen um zu sagen dieses gerät
ist komplett überflüssig denn wir haben bereits android geräte mit mehr leistung für weniger
geld aber wir sind noch am anfang das macht das gerät nur überteuert aber noch nicht nutzlos
kommen wir also zu den sachen die dieses gerät so dumm machen logitech hatte auf ihre präsentation
noch rumgeprotzt wie gut ein unternehmen sein muss um einen handheld zu erschaffen der für
cloud streaming optimiert ist und ja sie sind so gut darin dass man den ekfos gamepad zum
beispiel hast du hast du private hast du bedenken bei der privaten nutzung nicht wirklich gut darin
dass man den ekfos gamepad zum beispiel nicht mehr in das system integriert hat sondern das
eiken auf den startbettschirm ruft nur die webseite des game pass auf wait a minute das heißt im
endeffekt das ist eine webapp das heißt acht du scheiße cloud gaming über den browser auf
einem obacht was haben die sich dann dabei gedacht also wenn schon dann hätten die dann
xbox also ich hätte eigentlich gedacht dass dann xbox das ist eine web ach du kacke
dann hast du das problem zum beispiel du willst voice chat machen es funktioniert nicht richtig
weil es im browser läuft ach du große scheiße warum will man dann so was vor allem auch die
performance im browser dürfte noch mal ein paar prozentpunkte schlechter sein als in
irgendeiner native app mein klar du hast heute wirklich auch im browser die möglichkeit
performance technisch ordentlich was zu machen ich mein guck doch an es gibt multiplayer shooter
die im browser laufen aber trotzdem warum stadia ist weg ja auf den startbettschirm ruft nur die
webseite des game pass an nutzen den game pass am ende nur über den android browser nicht über
eine dedizierte applikation ich mein immerhin immerhin immerhin mit apple hätte schon mal
gar nicht funktioniert weil da wäre safari gewesen und mit safari kann es ja prinzipiell
nichts anfangen ist aus jeglicher technischer sicht daher wahrlich eine meisterklasse der
technischen leistung was logitech der abgeliefert hat dadurch ist es dann zum beispiel auch nicht
möglich bestimmte game pass spiele die man gerade spielt direkt auf den startbettschirm zu packen
so als eigene eigens als schnell startfunktion das wäre immerhin eine sinnvolle funktion die für
dieses gerät dann auch einzigartig wäre und gute einzigartige funktion waren hier eindeutig nicht
logitech ziel ok also startet ihr dann eurem browser basierten xbox game pass geht auf die
toilette und das bild fängt an zu zucken oder das signal bricht gar komplett ab cloud streaming
benötigt eine stabile internetverbindung wer keine rucklau sonstige probleme erleben will hat
entweder selbst das selbst wenn du perfekte wlan abdeckung daheim hast wenn wo da vorne mal wieder
der meinung ist jetzt nope jetzt halt nicht dann ist vorbei mit der latency und sinnvollen cloud
gaming ich guck mal bei mir droppt das stream random mal frames so manchmal wenn wo da vorne
da grad bock drauf hat das ist tödlich für cloud gaming signal oder nutzt am besten direkt ein
lahnkabel wenn das gegeben ist alles super außerwahl von eine wirklich sinnvolle alternative die echt
gut funktioniert wenn aber zwei bis drei wende das signal zu schwach machen kann man es vergessen
aber dann erhöht sich die eingabe verzögerung und danach werden außer man ist google und hat
wie bei stadia negative latency dann ist natürlich alles gut sagt google aber stadia ist eh
geschichte trotz negativ latency übersprungen wurde das gameplay ruckelig wird ist es halt
abricht weil das signal zu schwach wird es war von anfang an schwachsinn alter dieses gelaber
dabei stadia hat mich auch schon mal hart getriggert negativ latency alles klar
nüchster punkt handheld sind ziemlich toll um etwas unterwegs zu spielen hast eine lange
zugfahrt dann sind handheld absolute lebensretter um nicht vor lange weile zu sterben logitech
bewirbt das logitech g bewusst nicht als handheld zum mitnehmen was ich noch nie erlebt habe dass
eine firma ein handheld verkauft aber dabei die portabilität komplett was ich an diesen
werbespots immer so geil finde die leute ich will ich will ich will ich wissen wie oft wie oft
sie diese sachen aufgenommen genommen haben also diese darsteller aus diesen werbespots die haben
echt ein talent dafür uninteressante sachen interessiert anzugucken weil niemand schaut so
wenn er auf seiner switch spielt oder wenn er vor seinem rechner sitzt also guck mal niemand
schaut so auf seine konsole bewirbt das logitech g bewundern und niemand freut sich so da drüber
guck dir das mal an der keil ist so da sieht der sieht aus als ist das jetzt irgendwie als
als ist da irgendwie eine irgendwelche drogen drin oder so niemand guckt sein desktop pc oder seine
playstation oder seine switch oder sein handy oder so so an die sind alle schon ist schon übelst
high immer wenn sie sich die geräte angucken in diesen werbespots aber gut ist ja insofern auch
logisch natürlich soll die geräte mit spaß und sonst wie verbunden werden aber das ist immer so
fernab der realität wusst nicht als was ich noch nie erlebt habe dass eine firma ein handheld
verkauft aber dabei die portabilität komplett verschweigt hat natürlich seine gründe ich bin
jetzt mal so dreiß und behaupte dass so gut wie kein öffentliches bild vor gaming naja ihr schreibt
das drauf um perfektes zwingen von 1080p mit 60 bildern pro sekunde zu garantieren ich gehe
sogar so weit zwölf stunden batterie weh warum hat das ding zwölf stunden batterie lebenszeit
unter unter gaming bedingungen weil die spiele nicht darauf laufen wenn die spiele darauf laufen
das ding ordentlich cpu und ram aus der cpu und und gpu auslastung haben dann würde das auch nicht
zwölf stunden nicht zwölf stunden halten alles was das ding machen muss ist sein hat 264 decoder mit
strom versorgen dass er videos flüssig abspielen kann zu garantieren ich gehe sogar so weit zu
behaupten dass im icw land nicht mal bei bester wedernstärke cloud gaming funktioniert selbe
spiel im flugzeug und schiffen bis man es erfährt und nein das hat sie voll vergessen 5g bzw. man
kann keine sim karte reinpacken um mobile datum das ist so unsinnig bedeutet ich kann diesen
hand hält du müsstest du müsstest halt dann quasi in den hotspot aufmachen mit deinem iphone im
zug ich meine ich fahre eine der meistbefahrenen bahn strecken in deutschland da in frankfurt und
umgebung und ich habe trotzdem regelmäßig keine verbindung an den gleichen zwei halte stellen
das ist es funktioniert nicht du kannst das wenn überhaupt nur daheim verwenden und dann
ist halt die frage was will man damit unterwegs nutzen noch ohne einschränkungen zu hause und
halten wir das noch mal fest es hat eine zwei jahre alte mittelklasse cpu die auch noch mit
android arbeiten muss da verliert man schon einfach so keine ahnung ich verwende keine
zweite sim und kein whatsapp bedeutet bis auf cloud gaming kann man jetzt ordentlich super viel
ansonsten damit machen aber logitech sagt ganz stolz dass das gerät 12 stunden akkuleistung hat
ja no shit sherlock weil theoretisch die ganze zeit nur ein video abgespielt wird wenn ich aber
nur von zu hause ausspielen kann ist akkulaufzeit komplett egal ich habe überall steck da muss ja
mal sagen die leute im publikum ich habe schon interessiertere personen gesehen ja akkulaufzeit
ist nur wichtig wenn ich den akku nutzen muss unterwegs deswegen gibt es akkus und ich habe
schon gesehen dass leute fragten was ist mit emulation wo ich mir denke dass emulation interessierte
leute doch wissen müssen dass es für 350 euro langsam mal ganz davon abgesehen emulation hat
ja auch wieder hat er nichts mit streaming zu tun das muss er dann wirklich auf dieser kiste laufen
und dann ist es mit der akkulaufzeit auch nichts hin und ob so sag man mal einen schlechter als
mittelklasse smartphone von von paar jahren da drinnen an hardware ist so gut für emulation ist
naja alternativen gibt ein snapdragon 720 g ist jetzt nicht der schippsatz den ich 2022 für
emulationen nutzen würde viele lobis mit budget smartphones haben mehr leistung und kosten mit
controller attachment immer noch weniger als 350 euro und klar kommen auf vielen gaming news
seiten immer die vergleiche mit dem dek immerhin sind es drei geräte die ein bildschirm und
knöpfer haben die dinger also ganz im ernst dass das team deck und die switch das sind einfach
drei komplett unterschiedliche geräte ich meine am ehesten kannst du vielleicht noch die switch
und das team deck vergleichen wobei das ein hat eine nintendo konsole ist mit ja den v nachteilen
von nintendo konsolen und das andere vollständiger pc und das andere im prinzip in video player also
ich meine ok man kann es vergleichen man kann alles irgendwie vergleichen ob das so sinn macht
sei mal dahingestellt weil wenn du einfach nur sagst ja dieses display hat eine höhere
auflösung oder ja das hat eine schnellere cpu das ist in dem fall absolut nicht relevant weil
das eine ist in video player das andere ist quasi in x86 pc und das andere ist eine nintendo konsole
mit nintendo games und schlechte nintendo online kram aber es ergibt halt irgendwie keinen sinn sie
spielen spiele ab da hat man es als journalist echt schwer ein wenig technische kompetenz zu
zeigen und fängt an es geht es geht ja da auch überhaupt nicht mehr um technische kompetenz
es geht darum um quasi in gespür dafür zu haben also das ist glaube ich das einzige was da was da
aktuell noch zählt in gespür irgendwie dafür zu haben welche themen in kombination mit dem
passenden titel halt aufrufe bringt und wenn man jetzt sagen kann dieser logitech handheld zerstört
die nintendo switch dann geht das gut ab für eins zwei tage dass es mit der realität nichts
zu tun hat und eigentlich auch keinerlei grundlage gibt so was zu schreiben ja das ist wieder was
anderes teppwerte zu vergleichen das logitech g hat eine viel längere akkulaufzeit und ist leichter
als die switch und vor allem als das team deck und mit 1080p hat es ebenfalls von allen drei
handhelds die höchste auflösung diese vergleiche dafür hast du dafür hast du
video kompressions artefakte kein aber anbringen ich möchte aber ein aber anbringen das aber ist
ein ganzes gerät und zwar das schon genannte steam deck ich werde zu dem gerät noch ein
ganzes review machen möchte es aber vor logischer weise eine zeit lang testen um nicht nur meine
ersten gedanken wie heiße luft in die welt zu pusten was ich aber sagen kann ist dass man für
70 euro mehr einen vollwertigen portablen pc bekommt der so viel leistung besitzt dass man
ohne probleme windbag hd von der wu mit beiden bildschirmen und voller auflösung emulieren
kann das wird auf dem logitech stinken funktioniert schon probleme gamecube spiele
vernünftig zu emulieren ich kann dead rising 2 of the record unterwegs über vier stunden
lang spielen im 40 und außerdem ist die deck standardmäßig arch beide bei und wir wissen
alles was art schließungs verwendet muss gut sein all meine spiele auf steam zu greifen und fast
alle klappen auf den steam deck und natürlich könnte ich auch die xbox game pass cloud nutzen
weil sie funktioniert ja in dem browser das hat das logitech g ja bereits gut bewiesen dies soll
kein werbevideo für das steam deck sein es gibt gründe sich dieses gerät auch nicht zu kaufen
dazu kommen wir dann im review aber ich möchte einfach nur zeigen wie absolut unsinnig das logitech
g im vergleich ist weil es wird die bekloppt wenig leistungen auch zu wenig für vernünftige
emulationen man kann darauf nur zu hause vernünftig spielen und dort auch nur eingeschränkt keine
native anbindung der cloud dienste tencent hat ihre finger im spiel was ich immer etwas
unruhigen finde auch witzig dass dieses gerät nur ein paar tage vorher der welt präsentiert
wurde bevor google verkündete den stecker von stadia zu ziehen das timing ist einfach perfekt
diese kombination aus nutzen und preis gibt mir keine andere wahl als dem logitech g den preis
des dümmsten handhälts aller zeiten zu verleihen noch nie habe ich von einer großen tech firma ein
gerät gesehen dass kein einziges problem löst sondern nur neue schafft abgesehen von virtual
boy aber das ist eine ganz andere geschichte aber ja es ist ein produkt das absolut keine
zielgruppe besitzt außer leute die es nicht gebacken bekommen logitech g alternative auf
google einzugeben ich bin wirklich während wald mit den steen deck sehr bald jede neue
bestellung direkt rausschicken kann wird das logitech g erst mal nur in amerika erscheinen
kommt dann vielleicht anfangen des jahres auch in europa raus ich wüsste aber nicht wozu ernsthaft
ich bin immer offen für richtig gute gegenargumente aber ich habe jetzt mehrere tage viel darüber
nachgedacht mir fällt einfach nichts ein warum man sich dieses gerät kaufen sollte anstatt
eines stein steen deck oder die ganzen genau das habe ich mich auch gefragt vor allem weil die
leute das so abgefeiert haben auf twitter ich konnte es nicht nachvollziehen dass logitech g ist
technisch nutzlos und als gettet nutzlos und ich glaube all die leute die sich auf twitter auf
dieses gerät halten werden sehr enttäuscht sein wenn sie es dann in den händen halten so für
diesen kleinen rand kam ich also kurz zurück aus der pause ich werde es zirka geranntet
weiten oktoberwoche wieder regelmäßig wisst ihr warum solche produkte überhaupt her
wisst ihr warum solche produkte hergestellt werden ich kann mir das ich kann mir das bild
nicht vorstellen irgendein typa logitech kam auf die idee alter wir haben ja gar nichts mit cloud
gaming lass mal was mit cloud gaming machen der hat verdrängt dass die ganzen cloud gaming
geschichten der letzten jahre über alle nicht gut angekommen sind so hat der typ sich was cooles
überlegt ist zu seinem chef gegangen und hat ihm gesagt cloud gaming wir müssen cloud gaming
machen hat er hat es hat es ihm gepitcht und der chef hat gesagt jawoll wir machen cloud gaming was
heißt das egal wir machen cloud gaming so und dann hieß es auf geht's wir bauen jetzt was für
cloud gaming so und dann gab es manche leute die haben gesagt leute also leute also ein paar leute
mit hier und vielleicht techniker und entwickler aber sagt leute meint ihr das ist wirklich so
eine gute idee das klingt mir eher wie nach einem rohr krepierer mit ansage und dann hat das
management zu den leuten gesagt haha das kannst du gar nicht wissen du glaubst nur nicht an unsere
vision also sprich die wollen offenen auges gegen die wand fahren obwohl sie mal vielleicht
darauf hören sollten aber ich wollte es nicht anders ich kenne das ich habe schon oft genug
erlebt dass sachen absichtlich gegen die wand gefahren wurden weil man leuten die es eigentlich
besser wussten absichtlich ignoriert hat mit solchen komischen aussagen wie ja dann hast du
unsere vision nicht verstanden oder das kannst du ja gar nicht wissen unsere bla bla bla bla bla
bla und deswegen gibt es solche produkte hey markt bisschen auf wie bringst du kritik gegenüber
deinen vorgesetzten richtig rüber kommt drauf an was es ist ja also wenn es jetzt irgendwas rein
ja sachliches fachlich bezogenes ist dann ist es relativ einfach so nach dem motto irgendjemand
hatte ich genervt warum das noch nicht fertig ist und ein chef hat sie ersten tag vorher erzählt
kannst du mir sagen gut wie soll das schon fertig sein ich weiß das ja erst seit zwei stunden wenn
er rauskommt er wusste das seit zwei wochen ja gut hätte ich dir mal vorher sagen sollen ja
schwierig schwierig wird es dann halt bei so sachen die ja zum beispiel zum beispiel wenn du wenn du
immer das wenn du immer den eindruck hast irgendwie was weiß ich er behält sachen absichtlich für
sich oder er verkauft sachen als seine ideen die eigentlich deine gewesen sind also in dem fall
jetzt hier akhi deine ideen gewesen sind oder du hast das gefühl redet ich irgendwo schlechte
sonst wie das sind ja so sachen die sind oftmals die liegen nicht so auf der hand und das sind
schwierige themen anzusprechen weil der andere dann sofort in die defensive geht ja das ist
schwierig da habe ich auch kein patentrezept für ja ist es ich weiß es ist bei uns ähnlich wie
viele sachen sind bei uns schon offenen sehenden auges gegen die wand gefahren worden obwohl es
genug stimmen gab die gesagt haben leute das wird ein fail mit ansage aber da hieß es nein nein das
könnt ihr nicht wissen unsere vision ist doch klar ihr glaubt einfach nur nicht an unsere visionen
am ende reden die sich dann auch noch ein die entscheidung war richtig nur die leute hätten
nicht an ihre vision es ist ein bisschen wie meter meter verse facebook da gab es letztens
eine schöne news da musste ich echt kecken da musste ich richtig richtig richtig kecken
die benutzen das selber nicht also ich habe letztens gelesen die meter verse entwickler
bei facebook würden ihre eigene software nicht verwenden und daraufhin hat der chef
eine mail geschrieben ihr müsst meter verse lieben damit ihr es gut entwickeln können und die leute
wollten es halt nicht benutzen und irgendwie einen monat später hat der nächste chef in
der mail geschrieben leute kommt jetzt endlich mal rein und macht virtuelle meeting so ladet
eure freunde ein die eignen wirklich den scheiß nicht benutzen ich weiß nicht wo ich das gelesen
habe was bei golem was bei heise ich weiß es nicht mehr ja ja da meter verse entwickler
nutzten horizon world nicht die benutzen ja und irgendwann hat ein manager geschrieben
ne das war was anderes dann war es andere andere news da hat er hat irgendwas geschrieben
ihr müsst meter verse lieben oder sowas was war es vielleicht ok dann dann stand bei computer
bild eben auch fast aber nicht das was ich geleben haben genau also der typ muss ich
weiß das ist das ist das ist das ist hier golem news war es richtig chat genau hier ja genau es ist euer job euch in
hurra also sprich die entwickeln irgendwas auf auftrag was halt absoluter roll clip hier ist und
dann wird von ihnen verlangt ihr müsst es gut finden also das sind das sind genau solche dinger
wo offenen august gegen die wand gefahren wird und man im endeffekt dann noch den leuten die es
entwickelt haben den vorwurf macht dass sie nicht an die vision geglaubt haben und so ein bullshit
ein leitender angestellter fragt ihn die runde warum die leute hier also eher im gegenteil
blabla veröffentlicht im internen memo von september 2022 haben die beim meter zuständigen
mitarbeiter keine große lust auf ihre eigene virtuelle welt ein leitende angestellter fragt
in die runde warum ist das so warum lieben wir das produkt dass wir entwickelt haben nicht so
sehr dass wir es ständig verwenden naja weil es weil es arbeit ist ihr habt die leute beauftragt
das zu entwickeln nach euren vorstellungen und die vorstellungen sind einfach schwach sind und
unsinniger crap den kein mensch braucht ja zumindest manager logik ist wenn wir es nicht
lieben wie können wir erwarten dass es unsere benutzer lieben ja dann denkt ihr ein ordentliches
produkt aus da können doch die leute können auch die entwickler nicht dafür lucifer dankeschön für
den sub so und zwei wochen später ging es dann weiter ging es dann weiter da war da ist er sauer
da ist er sauer gewesen dass die leute immer noch nicht ins meta verse gehen hat geschrieben jeder
in dieser organisation hat den job sich in horizon world zu verlieben wir können das nicht tun ohne
es zu verwenden kommt da rein und jetzt sollen sie sich mit kollegen und freunden online verabreden
aber die wollen nicht die wollen nicht mit einer 3d brille oder 3d vor herz hat rumsitzen und
irgendwelche meetings abhalten mit dem typ der neben ihnen sitzt aus dem können sie einfach
vor erzelt verwenden ja vor übrigens die vor erzelt entwickler die verwenden verbringen
eigentlich sehr viel zeit in vor erzelt und gucken sich das an das ist aber halt auch nicht
so dieses dumme business gelaber sondern geht es eher um ja user created content und spaß an der
freut so dass das ist solche produkte wie dieses logitech hand hält kommen genau aus solchen
gründen raus genau aus dem was ich eben erzählt habe und das was man auch bei dieser meta verse
geschichte gut sieht das haben sie da haben sie da hat irgendein manager einem anderen manager
was gepitcht und jetzt haben sie sich eingeredet dass es die nächste große vision die man verfolgen
muss und jeder der sagt ob das so eine gute idee ist ist ein zweifler und glaubt nicht an die vision
und am ende liegt es nicht daran dass es einfach eine absolut dämliche entscheidung gewesen ist
wofür eigentlich manager da sind ja eben entscheidungen zu treffen und nach möglichkeit
keine dämlichen entscheidungen und dann sind am ende noch die entwickler schuld weil sie
die vision nicht verstanden haben jetzt aber alles letztendlich blödsinn weil
jetzt was wollte ich jetzt sagen lull ich kann nicht chat lesen und reden das funktioniert nicht
letztendlich ist es egal weil es im endeffekt eher dann dem manager zu verhängnis wird als
irgendein programmierer da dran weil der hat halt gelitten wenn sein wenn sein drittes projekt
gegen die wand fährt dann ist er halt dann nicht mehr da außer bei uns wo manager noch
so viel gegen die wand fahren können und immer noch da sind wo ich mich also bei uns frage ich
also da wo ich arbeite frage ich mich teilweise echt wie geht das so viel zeug gegen die wand
gefahren so viel kram verkackt und immer noch die gleichen leute gut es liegt auch bei uns
daran dass es sonst keiner machen will aber aus diesem grund gibt es so sachen wie dieses
komische logitech hand hält komm wir gucken uns noch eine runde smart home inspiration an
als nächstes automatisches badezimmer exzellent
müssen die entwickler bei facebook auf na klar na klar was meinst du dann die haben ein internes
facebook in facebook jaja natürlich am besten ist leute muss ich mir was von mir von der arbeit
erzählen wo es ähnlich wird also es ging mal es ging mal darum ob ich muss ich muss es anders
erzählen also ich arbeite bei einer bank in frankfurt das wüsste er und wir haben natürlich neben dem
was so klassisches bankzeug macht haben wir auch noch außendienst leute die beispielsweise zu
irgendeiner oma heim fahren und der dann erzählen hier sie sollten mal bei uns jetzt irgendwie was
neues abschließen oder sowas sie braucht jetzt unbedingt eine neue versicherung oder sie braucht
jetzt unbedingt mehr stonks und aktien und sonst was also die die gehen dann heim zu den leuten und
erzählen den irgendwas was sie angeblich brauchen außendienst leute gut die verdienen viel kohle
muss man sagen ja also anteilmäßig ist das ist das wirklich nicht nicht zu verachten also die
schaffen ordentlich da kohle ran das heißt eines der wichtigsten sachen die wir haben ist ein system
wo beispielsweise außendienst leute verträge einreichen können berechnungen durchführen können
für irgendwelche kunden in sie was verkaufen und sonst was also sprich das womit die täglich
arbeiten und damit sie besser ihren kram verkaufen können wo wir im endeffekt halt der gesamte laden
mit auch was ich kohle verdient so und jetzt ist es so vor ein paar jahren hatten irgendwelche
high IQ manager die idee damit die innen dienst leute also quasi ich und also IT und programmierer
und ein entwickler admins programmierer der fops leute klaut also die gesamte IT dass die ein
besseres gespür für quasi so wie haben sie das genannt für den für die dna des außendienstes
irgendwie sowas haben sie damals gesagt das muss man sich mal vorstellen also das quasi der
innen dienst ein besseres gespür für die dna des außendienst hört sich schon unglaublich
dämlich an für die dna des außendienst bekommt hatten sie hatten sie die glorreiche idee dass
und es ist kein witz das war das war wirklich absoluter hirnfurz den saden da ging es darum
dass die leute die bei uns für das mailing system zuständig sind also sprich darüber wo
sich die außendienst leute leute untereinander mails schreiben können mails erkunden schicken
können und eben auch mobil das auf ihr handy sünden können was dann auch zehn jahre gespeichert
wird und alles möglich also es gibt es gibt so ein kommunist und es heißt nicht mails es heißt
nicht mailing system es heißt eigentlich irgendwie smart communications oder sowas wie sie das
verkauft haben ist auch wurscht zumindest es ist im kern ist es ein mailing mailing system ja und
die leute die damals damit gearbeitet haben die haben halt öfters mal anfragen bekommen von
entwicklung von den entwicklern und dem support wenn es probleme gab so nach dem motto ja irgendwie
in diesem ungünstigen fall wird die mail nicht richtig im posteingang angezeigt und sowas in
der richtung kam da kam immer anfragen zu denen sondern eines tages kam auch so eine anfrage kann
ich so kann ich heute noch gut dran erinnern kam auch so eine anfrage ich glaube es war was
relativ simples irgend einer hat eine mail gelöscht und irgendwie hat er seinen papierkorb auch
gelehrt und man musste man musste die mail quasi aus aus dem archiv aus dem archiv wieder rausholen
und bei dem irgendwie ins mail postfach wieder reinschieben eigentlich nichts nix großartiges
also relativ easy so und dann kriegt kriegt der typ der es damals bei uns gemacht hat hat die
anfrage bekommen und auf einmal will er sich dann einloggen in dem in dem mailing system um die
mail zu restoren und da heißt es nee du darfst sie nicht mehr einloggen gesagt ja wie soll ich
die mail restoren wenn ich mich in dem eigentlich system nicht einloggen darf und dann kam allen
ernst die aussage das muss so sein weil rein rechtlich gesehen dürfen nur leute die so einen
außen dienstvertrag unterschrieben haben zugriff bekommen auf das live mailing system oder ist ja
gut aber wie soll ich denn dann die mail wieder herstellen und dann war die antwort schließ doch
ein beratervertrag ab und daraufhin kam es dann ohne scheiß daraufhin kam es dann damit der
innen dienst eine best ein besseres gespür für die dna des außen dienstes entwickelt soll der
innen dienst doch auch einen beratungsvertrag abschließen also dass man dann quasi aus dass
man dann quasi außen dienst quasi ein die gleichen vertrag haben wie die aussicht und da haben alle
gesagt was wollt ihr uns verarschen und ich glaube niemand von uns hat hier so ein vertrag im
leben hätte ich diesen vertrag nicht abgeschrieben hätte ich den vertrag nicht unterschrieben
es könnte durchaus sein dass boni winkt derjenige der uns offiziell dann vermittelt die wollen
allen ernst dass wir einen beratervertrag machen dass wir wieder weiter unsere arbeit ausführen
können da habe ich mir auch gesagt alter wie verstrahlt kann man eigentlich im kopf sein dass
man denkt das ist eine gute idee also das war eines der der wirsten sachen ich da je erlebt
hat er hat keiner abgeschlossen und ein paar tage später nachdem die leute weiterhin gemeckert
haben dass ihre mails nicht da sind hat mal wieder den zugang erleichtert oder hat man
wieder den zugang ermöglicht also meine güte das gab schon abgedreht das zeug so also was
gucken wir uns hier an automatisches badezimmer auf geht's um den alltag zu erleichtern habe
ich probiert alle täglichen aufgaben die gleich sind zu automatisieren er hat einen schönen
floorplan in seinem home assistant ich hatte auch mal einen floorplan aber ich habe keinen
floorplan mehr weil ich es unsinnig fand ich habe jetzt tabs für unterschiedliche räume
beziehungsweise ein bisschen kopiert nach funktion floorplan habe ich nimmer dazu gehört auch
meine tägliche badezimmer routine diese beginnt indem ich mich auf meiner withings excellent
das mache ich auch mal ins immer bloß dass es bei mir eine schau schau me me scale ist
wo das ganze per bluetooth übertragen wird hat waage wiege sobald diese waage eine neue
gewichtsmessung erkennt startet alexa meine dusch playlist auf spotify gut das ist eine
gute idee hey das finde ich nice das ist eine wirklich gute idee weil ich wiege mich auch
jedes mal morgens und ich habe mich schon öfters gefragt wie erkennt eigentlich das
bad dass ich morgens im bad bin das beste ist wenn es eine neue gewichtsmessung gibt
das ist eine wirklich gute idee sobald moment war das ein custom zahnbürsten und sprachzylinder
halter ist 3d gedruckt oder ist er aus beton gegossen oder beides sobald ich dusche wird
die spiegelheizung angeschaltet damit der spiegel durch die luftfeuchtigkeit in der
mitte nicht beschlägt eine spiegelheizung lasst das mal friday's for future hören alles
vorbei nach dem duschen erkennt das smart home dass ich fertig da ist direkt das plakat
vorm fenster wenn die mitkriegen dass eine spiegelheizung hat zusätzlich die spiegellampe
ist auch sinnlose energieverschwendung spiegelheizung das muss ich wirklich sagen man kann das
ding auch einfach mit einem handtuch abputzen oder man lüftet halt noch mal kurz zehn minuten
bevor man weiter also das spiegelheizung finde ich tatsächlich auch ein bisschen aus da die
feuchtigkeit nun durch das fenster nach draußen entweichen kann und der spiegel nicht weiter
beschlägt um dann nicht unnötig zu heizen schaltet sich zu den das ist gut das ist gut das ist gut
ja sobald man das war das habe ich auch das habe ich auch ich habe mir einen fensterkontakt im
badezimmer durch die tür verlässt und keine bewegung merken und ding da schalten sich alle
anderen lampen auch aus was die archiv webseite funktioniert nicht so richtig
echt nicht da vielleicht gab es ein update gestern so also was geht was geht nicht was
was soll was soll ich machen irgendwas eingeben oder hier oben war was ok stream
jetzt geht es wieder siste chat
möglich wird das ganze durch ein celli 3 em in meinem sicherungskasten der den
gesamtverbrauch der wohnung da in der wohnung eine elektrische habe ich nicht gecheckt jetzt
das badezimmer durch die tür verlässt und keine bewegung mehr erkannt wird
schalten sich alle anderen lampen auch aus ja möglich wird das ganze durch ein celli 3 em
in meinem sicherungskasten der den gesamtverbrauch der wohnung da in der wohnung ein elektrischer
durchlaufer zerbautes lässt sich das duschen durch einige geschickte abfragen ja ok das
verstehe ich das wasserheizen des verbrauchstroms über drei phasen erkennen die spiegelheizung und
die spiegellampe werden über einen unterputz celli 2.5 angesteuert leute ich habe mich
gebäden lassen von dem celli 2.5 das habe ich euch ja noch gar nicht erzählt guck mal wir haben
doch hier wir haben noch den stream gemacht zu meiner hoftor steuerung da hier guck mal wo ich
erst wo ich erst mit dem celli 3 dran wollte und dann festgestellt habe das funktioniert nicht
wo wir dann hier so uns ein paar relays zusammen gelötet haben im stream hier guck mal da hier
seht ihr den esp und die relays hier die relays sind die relays die relays sind da also und ich
dachte mir hey bevor ich sowas selbst baue warum kaufe ich nicht einfach ein celli 2.5 der hat
ja zwei relays drinne ist auch in einem schönen gehäuse dass ich das hier unten rein kleben kann
und gut ist so problem ist jetzt nur also hier seht ihr meine bastelkonstruktion ja den esp
spannungswandern esp und relays dran das problem ist jetzt nur der celli 2.5 hat keine potentialfreien
relays das ist quasi kein wir schalten wir faken den schalterdruck zwischen diesen und
diesem pinn sondern es ist ground und dings hier ist irgendwie auf der gemeinsamen leitung das
heißt ich kann mit dem celli 2.5 obwohl der zwei relays drinne hat das teil überhaupt nicht wirklich
schalten ohne dass es eventuell kaputt geht seitdem es die watts auf youtube gibt brauche ich das
erschief nicht mehr ich denke der channel wurde gebannt auf youtube oder gibt es da wieder neun
ich habe ich habe gehört das wurde gebannt auf youtube ne gibt's wieder ne sagt es wieder
frida ist der geht wieder dachte er wurde gebannt kate irgendjemand meinte der wurde gebannt also
ist denn ich betreibe den da nicht selbst ah cool nice so der celli 2.5 wird keine potentialfreien
relays also sprich der da verwendet quasi den gleichen das gleiche minus beziehungsweise den
gleichen ground wieder celli selbst zum schalten also du kannst jetzt nicht mit dem relay einfach
beispielsweise hier dazwischen schalten mit dem relay geht das da schaltest du quasi hier
dazwischen so und das geht beim celli nicht weil die celli relays eben nicht quasi so durch schalten
von eins nach zwei von von einem zum anderen sondern irgendwie das gemeinsam hier mit verwenden
das ist doof ich habe mich gebaten lassen von dem celli das heißt ich muss doch meine
eigenkonstruktion bauen oder ich kaufe ein celli uni das funktioniert auch er hat zwei
relays die potentialfrei sind dabei das funktioniert auch tja aber jebaited ich dachte mir kaufste
celli mit zwei relays wird schon funktionieren nein funktioniert nicht also man könnte ja denken
man könnte ja denken die also celli hier minus dc minus und schwachsinn dc plus dc minus hier an n
und l so versorgt den celli mit strom und man könnte jetzt denken das hier sind die relays
also quasi das relay schalter zwischen sv1 und 0 1 und sv 2 und 0 2 nein das stimmt aber nicht
das hier ist der input schalter input schalter 2 und input schalter 1 also ich könnte an das
celli beispielsweise einen knopf anschließen über den ich dann die relays schalten lasse wenn
die relays schalten dann schalten die zwischen 0 2 und l beziehungsweise 0 1 und l was das gleiche
ist wie das hier also der crown vom celli und das ist alles das gleiche das heißt das sind keine
potentialfreien relays sondern es benutzt das gleiche vom celli mit das heißt wenn man
das potentialfrei schalten will wenn das dabei steht dass man das machen soll dann geht das mit
dem celli nicht was doof ist mit dem celli 1 geht's wenn man sich mal ancelli 1 dass man
jemand sieht was der unterschied ist weil wir wir wird champ diagram da hast du genau da hast du
so hast du schalter input hast den celli zum vergleichen und hier hast du quasi das relay
das schaltet hier dazwischen also wenn das relay im celli schaltet dann überbrückt es die hier
dazwischen das heißt es hat nichts mit dem anderen kram zu tun was doof ist jetzt habe ich den celli
2 da und ich weiß nicht was ich damit machen soll
wie auch immer sie das machen das ist zumindest dafür nicht verwendbar ne ne der celli hat
kein mosfet relay da ich hör das wirklich klicken im celli also es kein transistor
der schalte ne ne das ist klickt wirklich wirklich sowas was man sich unter relay
vorstellt wie lernt man sowas eigentlich
wie spricht man es denn sonst aus
wie spricht man es denn sonst aus ach so ja wenn man es auf deutsch ausspricht relay ja
ich bin noch nie auf die idee gekommen das französisch auszusprechen
alter die war aber glücklich beim aufnehmen des videos dies happy sieht man die richtig an
relay relay ist mir lieber
sind wir stehen geblieben keck alter video hier also das funktioniert mit dem celli nicht so
so soweit waren wir aber ja wie man das lernt ganz einfach indem man damit rumbasteln
und wie gesagt ich habe was elektronik sachen angeht jetzt ja auch nicht so den großen plan
deswegen mache ich an 230 volt auch nichts da habe ich zu viel schiss vor dass ich mich umbringe
bei ich habe auch schon paar leds abgefackelt mal hier mit mit blöden schaltung aber gut
einfach rumbasteln was anderes bleibt die nicht übrig learning by doing ja genau und und und
google ganz viel google ist wichtig moin patrick aber was anderes ja zum beispiel hier ist das
der berühmte berühmte small clip es hat geplinkt das ganz kurz ok habt ihr es gesehen ich habe
eben nicht hingeguckt mal das guck hier da oben da oben raucht rauchzeit kann schon mal vorkommen
ja wobei dass es geraucht hat in diesem clip das lag daran weil das irgendeinen billig china
chinesen spannungswandler war der nicht damit klar gekommen ist mit was auch immer das lag an
dem china spannungswandler unter china spannungswandler der war so gut dass wenn er kaputt geht er einfach
komplett input durchleitet auf output das heißt eigentlich ist ein spannungswandler gewesen von
keine ahnung 12 volt auf 3,3 und der ist dann aus irgendwelchen gründen kaputt gegangen und auf
einmal war am output auch 12 volt und hat halt den ganzen controller gekrillt china billig china
chinesen billig graben halt so gucken wir uns aber erst mal das video hier weiter an 2.5 angesteuert
die fenster und die heizungsthermostate sind von elgato if und hängen über eine extend bridge
im wlan schön aufgeräumter server schrank der bewegung das stimmt zumindest in der ecke
melda und die decken langen sind von philips you home assistant dient als steuerzentrale
ist eines der overpriced dinger überhaupt wir laufen alle daten zusammen und die einzelnen geräte
leises gamma setting für den bildschirm werden vernetzt und ausgewertet also das was du gebaut
hast ist schon ein sehr starrer ablauf aber wenn das eben jeden morgen gleich ist ist es natürlich
sensationell um so einen ablauf runter zu also der trigger der trigger mit der waage den finde ich
gut denn wenn ich mir mal merken ja dieses gefühl jedes mal wenn so eine kleine automation einfach
funktioniert im zweifelsfall sogar bevor man dran denkt mir war auch nicht bewusst dass es im
luxusleben inzwischen behalte spiegel im badezimmer gibt wusste ich auch nicht aber auf jeden fall
sehr nett könnte ich mich auch dran gewöhnen vielleicht finde ich ja auch irgendwas wofür ich
die automatische schildkröte dann hat stefan etwas geschickt das winterquartier für pumba
heißt hoffentlich ist das nicht irgendeine pflanze dann haben wir schon ein tier für den
titel dieses format menschentiere automation sieht auf jeden fall wild aus was da im hintergrund
passiert schauen wir mal rein ich möchte euch das automatisierte winterquartier meiner schildkröte
vorstellen jetzt dabei handelt es sich um einen ungebauten kühlschrank oder schildkröte in den
was ist das denn halber selbst gebaute grafikkarte die winterstarter ist für sie lebensnotwendig
dafür benötigt sie eine gleichbleibende temperatur zwischen 4 bis 6 grad Celsius und
ausreichend sauerstoff das gehirn der automatisieren ist ein raspberry pi dieser reguliert die
temperaturen in dem ich habe gerade nicht hingeguckt wo die türaufgang ich habe mich
gerade übelst erschreckt als die tür aufgegangen ist hier dieses durch dieses geräusch ich habe
in chat geguckt nicht gesehen dass das gerade und ich habe dieses dieses aufgeh geräusch gehört
habe ich kann übelst erschreckt nebenbei bis 6 grad Celsius und ausreichend sauerstoff das
gehirn der automatisierung ist dieses aufgeh geräusch ich habe gerade nicht hingeguckt und
habe nur gehört irgendwas quietscht hier im hintergrund also der kühlschrank ist wirklich
advanced die temperaturen in dem er den kühlkompressor des kühlschranks steuert weiterhin kümmert
er sich um die notwendige sauerstoffversorgung in dem er den kühlschrank regelmäßig belüftet auf
einer webseite welche moment moment die schildkröte wohnt im kühlschrank winterstarre
liebt besteht die möglichkeit alle einstellungen zu verändern der kühlschrank informiert seinen
besitzer natürlich auch über durchgeführte aktionen zur umsetzung habe ich bewusst keine
vorgefertigten lösung vio broker verwendet sondern habe alle abläufe und programme selbst
geschrieben warum was hat er da alles gebaut das ist das ist sein telegramm oder was ist das
was was sieht man jetzt das telegramm was sieht man denn hier ne was ist das rocket chat oder
telegramm ganz einfach mit dem projekt habe ich mir selbst das programmieren beigebracht
also programmieren lernen wenn die schildkröte ein tierleben steuern wobei du im zweifelsfall
natürlich den kühlschrank auch einfach selber aufmachen könntest und lüften oder einstellen
wenn es noch ein eisbrocken drinne liegt dann hat es nicht so ganz funktioniert alle
funktionen des kühlschranks findet ihr in der video beschreibung dann verlinke ich euch aber
steffans wieder schlecht in meiner video beschreibung damit ihr in seiner video beschreibung sieht
äußerst etwas aus beschreibung finden könnt steckt in der küche befindet sich ein zweiter
raspberry pi dieser zeigt nochmals die wichtigsten daten auf zwei zeilen des plays an über die
angebrachten schalter kann man unabhängig von einem handy oder computer aktionen ausführen
etwa die belüftung des kühlschranks auf jeden fall ein sehr schönes projekt um das alles zu
lernen und ich freue mich für pumba dass er oder sie bestens klimatisiert durch den winter
kommt wenn ihr auch interessante smartphone dinge gebaut habt dann schickt ihr gerne über
das formular auf zeug.ch zeigen zu mir und für jeden dessen einsendungen gezeigt werden gibt
es ein 50 euro amazon gutschein so dann hat heiko was zu lg think u waschmaschinen in homekit
geschickt dann schon mal rein ich habe noch nie so ein video gemacht aber als andreas ich glaube
aber ich komme demnächst auch nicht zumindest um so ein fake homekit dabei für meinen hof vor
sagte dass die lg think u waschmaschine nicht ins homekit integriert ist da dachte ich das geht
nicht da können wir so nicht stehen lassen das wäre ein unding wenn man das so stehen lässt ja
natürlich ist es die beste methode die tür aufzumachen du kannst ja den du kannst ja den
kühlschrank schlecht runter regeln also zumindest nicht so dass ich das in der geschwindigkeit
beziehungsweise in der genauigkeit anpassen lässt ja die tür geht nur auch für sauerstoff du
könntest recht haben dann ist es misst was ich gerade erzählt habe dann regelt er die
temperatur vielleicht über den im kühlschrank eingebauten zeug aber das für sauerstoff wird
natürlich hat er das gesagt oder oder hast du dir einfach feifett IQ technisch den teil dabei
gedacht ok das hat er gesagt ja dann habe ich dann habe ich nicht zugehört ok ich meine der
hat seine waschmaschine die geht ins homekit rein und er weiß dass er dann ist das müssen wir
ihnen sagen darum habe ich dieses video gemacht und ich hoffe es gefällt dir und auch du wirst
deine waschmaschine demnächst in homekit nutzen können viel spaß das hast du auf jeden fall ich
muss mir mal überlegen wie ich das angehe wir haben ja eine lg dings waschmaschine die theoretisch
im wifi ist und theoretisch in der praktik also meine waschmaschine muss man meine waschmaschine
das ist eines der teil die hat tatsächlich weder der trockener noch die waschmaschine sind im
wlan reingehen unter plugins das homebridge lg sink u plugin installieren und schon kann man
die homekit juckt mich nicht ich mach mal weiter gartenschlauch mit nfc klarstellen daniel schaltet
seine bewässerung per lfc hallo ich habe eine ganz kurze automation für meinen garten die
erleichtert das leben ein wenig in diesem video nur ganz kurz ich habe hier man sieht das hinter
dem silbernen gaffer tape ein nfc tag versteckt der ist so mit einigermaßen wasserdicht und
funktioniert ganz gut auch schon seit einem jahr wenn ich diesen nfc text gerne mit meinem
handy dann das dauert moment weil die pumpe ich sag es immer wieder leute nfc text ist eine
geile erfindung ist total underrated und under used weil sein handy hast du überall dabei meistens
zumindest nfc tag ist wirklich gut ich schalte ich schalte die heizung beziehungsweise den
heizlüfter bei mir im bad auch mit einem nfc tag an und aus weil es ist so oft vorgekommen dass
ich auf dem klo gesessen habe und gedacht habe ach mir ist kalt man könnte jetzt mal den heizlüfter
anmachen da bin ich nicht hingekommen deswegen hatte heizlüfter mittlerweile eine wlan steckdose
und ich könnte es entweder übers handy schalten da müsste ich die home assistant app aufmachen
oder zumindest mal in die widget zwischen und einschalten nee ich habe mir den nfc tag an den
korb geklebt wo das klo papier drin ist dann gehe ich aufs klo und sobald mir es kühl ist
halte ich einfach kurz mein handy an den nfc tag und zack geht der heizlüfter an habe sogar ich
habe sogar ein video dazu nfc
die meisten werden wahrscheinlich auf twitter geschrieben wie toll das funktioniert soll
ich machen twitter video qualität heute morgen ist mir aufgefallen ich bin ins bad gegangen und
hier ist relativ kühl ich habe ja da so ein heizer steht aber ihr seht ja da kommt man nicht
hin wenn man auf dem klo sitzt jetzt habe ich mir an der stelle hier pass mal auf guck da nfc
tag und jetzt und jetzt und jetzt halte das blab blub geht an und wieder aus
dann wieder an und jetzt habe ich auf dem klo warm ohne dass ich auf warum fokussiert das nicht
warum ist die twitter video qualität eigentlich so kotten schlecht warum sitzt du auf dem klo
naja wenn man in ruhe kackt kann man da schon mal zehn minuten sitzen aber will man nicht das
einem kalt ist bei doch vollkommen relatable oder das ganze funktioniert nur weil ich hier
außerdem muss ich mein 3000 euro klo lohnen die habe ich da nicht mehr dran die sind die war
nicht so geil dafür ich habe jetzt eine steckdose dran da ist auch noch usb dran dass ich mein handy
laden kann im bad falls ich mal länger im bad bin ich habe meine bad steckdose das
heute kastenfirmen wie kommst du an die zeitung gar nicht die liegt einfach nur noch da weil
ich das aber noch nicht abgestellt habe ich lese eigentlich kaum noch ct offline ist gerne den
nfc tag mit meinem das geht nur mit dem mit dem neuen iphone und ich kann den nfc tag und dann
geht das ganze über home assistant also das mein heim automatisierungslösung schickt das
ein event über shortcuts an home assistant und home assistant löst dann hier es ist sogar gesund
länger zu kacken als zu kurz weil das übers wehladen das event an dieser tas motor steckdose aus
ob das ganze einzuschalten und wieder auszuschalten natürlich man kann auch man kann da auch natürlich
doch ist es wenn man einfach nur schnell aufs klo rennen das in 15 sekunden rausdrückt und
wieder auf und wieder auf springt da kommt die verdauung gar nicht so richtig mehr in gange
bis sie ein bisschen sitzen in ruhe man muss ja da keine viertel stunde sitzungen machen
bin jetzt stehen geblieben ja so sieht das bei mir aus
per shortcut an home assistant genau nfc tag scannen also du brauchst aber du brauchst aber
die home assistant app damit geht es am einfachsten du kannst den nfc tag direkt in die home assistant
app scannen und dann kannst du das über einen shortcut triggern lassen wenn der gescannt wird
ohne dass du es bestätigen muss das ist das gute daran normalerweise musst du das interaktiv
interaktiv bestätigen also sieht das aus ja und wie das viel das funktioniert ist ganz geht das
auch ohne app naja das scannen des nfc tags geht ohne app da reicht shortcuts für dass du dann was
mit ausführen kannst das senden an deine hau an deine heim automatisierung das muss ja auf
irgendeinen weg muss das ja gehen dass es an die steckdose letztendlich geschickt wird das
mache ich über home assistant das geht prinzipiell natürlich auch mit einem web request direkt an die
steckdose kannst du auch machen kannst du direkt über shortcuts web request an die steckdose schicken
wenn du keine home assistant oder kein kein hub oder keine heim automatisierungslösung hast
irgendjemand hat gefragt wie das mit dem nfc funktioniert das ist kein nfc chip zumindest
ist es nicht so dass der nfc tag was machen würde nfc das ist ja fid das funktioniert folgendermaßen
du hast einen du hast einen tag da ist quasi eine große antenne drin im endeffekt so und über
diese antenne wird dann quasi ein ganz kleiner chip kann man es noch nicht mal nennen ein ganz
kleines stück speicher im endeffekt mit strom versorgt und du kannst dann eine nummer du kannst
minimal starten auslesen und die stromversorgung geht halt darüber dass das handy nahe genug
dran gehalten wird und die antenne quasi das aufnimmt und dieser das was du in energie über
die antenne aufnehmen reicht gerade so dass der speicher chip da drinnen mit energie versorgt
wird so dass dein handy daraus was auslesen kann also der nfc chip das ist nicht der der
letztendlich die automatisierungen auslöst sondern das handy löst die automatisierung aus nachdem es
den nfc tag gescannt hat wenn du home assistant hast hast du doch eh die home assistant app
wahrscheinlich auf dem handy oder wenn nicht wie gesagt du kannst das über htp requests machen
aber es ist mit der home assistant tatsächlich deutlich einfacher was für heizungsthermostate
hast du ich habe fritz heizungsthermostate ich habe ein bisschen was ausprobieren ich muss sagen
die funktionieren mit abstand am besten von allen die ich ausprobiert habe und die bluetooth
dinger waren ganz schlecht also ganz ganz grausam das was jetzt letztens shelly rausgebracht hat
ne ne ne nicht shelly akara show me akara rausgebracht hat das habe ich seit jahren schon das
gleiche thermostat und das war kacke ich weiß nicht warum das jetzt auf einmal gut sein soll
nur weil es vom anderen hersteller lizenziert wurde und ich muss sagen also ich bin mit den
fritz thermostaten bisher ganz happy die reagieren ein bisschen langsam also wenn du jetzt abschickst
jetzt eins plus temperatur in deiner steuerung was da kann sein dass es erst zehn minuten später
passiert aber wenn man seine heizungssteuerung automatisch macht so nach dem motto abends zum
fernseh gucken machts im wohnzimmer warm dann ist das nicht schlimm ansonsten kannst du immer noch
auf den knopf drücken für jetzt abrufen kann man auch ein nfc tag konfigurieren der ein in das
gastwLAN ein wählt weiß ich nicht du kannst aber nur qr code daneben kleben und den kann man
scannen nfc tag habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert geht bestimmt auch mein warum soll man sich nicht
in einem in einem nfc tag speichern können geht bestimmt auch so gucken wir mal weiter
jetzt fehlt bloß noch gerdehner auf usb
also auf den ersten blick ist natürlich ein bisschen umständlich sein handy da jedes mal
dran halten zu müssen ja man könnte auch knopf drücken ich mein knopf drücken oder handy an
nfc tag halten ok wenn da ein wasserhahn hängt die man auch einfach aufdrehen könnte aber es ist
ja immer die frage was dahinter passiert ich wollte gerade sagen vielleicht ist das gar nicht
der wasserhahn letztendlich sondern es wird hinten im keller was geschaltet dann ist es wieder was
anderes gesagt dass eine pumpe anspringt ja und da müsstest du zur pumpe rennen und den knopf
drücken ja genau dann ist es sinnvoll ist es so natürlich sehr viel angenehmer wir haben ja auch
eine wassersteckdose und ich musste auch erst einmal die pumpe anschmeißen damit der druck
drauf ist und anfangs musste ich sogar noch in unserer bewässerungssteuerung das entsprechende
ventil aufmachen das ist dann ein punkt und denkbar einfacher ist mal eben das handy dran
kann da kann ich mich mit identifizieren das finde ich so auch besser gerade mit mehreren
leuten im haushalt die vielleicht nicht alle die jeweiligen apps von den pumpen doch doch
ios kannst du auch qr code scannen also nfc text ist weiß ich nicht also mit für wlan das
habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert die hersteller installiert haben die pumpe aus dem garten im
winter stellts ok das ist ja uralt ok schnee du meinst diese pumpe hier hallo jungs du meinst
moment schön den bodenfilm ja max dass man nicht sieht exzellent da die pump max pumpe
jetzt bin ich schon an der pumpe vorbei wo ist die pumpe
ich bin noch im gartenhäuschen ok hier da ist die pumpe
das ist mein garten die schweizer lachen sich kaputt keck von wegen tiefer schnee
also ich muss mal ein bild finden die pumpe ja die geht wieder aber die pumpe sieht mittlerweile
anders aus die pumpe hat hier unten jetzt einfach eine pumpe dran und nicht mehr dieses
komische ding zum von hand pumpen und ja die funktioniert wieder
und auch ohne dass man da jedes jahr irgendwelche komische essig reiniger zeug reinschüttet
die funktioniert wieder auf jeden fall danke daniel für die idee so matthias hat uns ein
infodisplay geschickt schauen wir mal rein ich habe mir an der eignungstür ein kleines
das da eingebaut und zwar eine information ich sehe nix ich sehe nix wenn ich da draufdrücke
das geht erst an wenn man draufdrückt gute idee gute idee fensterstatus vorm rausgehen
gute idee habe ich anderweitig gelöst ich habe oben und unten im flur ein fire hd10
tablet als dashboard hängen wo man das drauf sieht da kann man dann wenn man durch den flur
läuft beispielsweise wenn man rausgehen will oder abhauen will oder oder wegfahren will oder
irgendwo hingehen will kann man einfach einen blick auf das dashboard werfen und dann sieht man
auf bevor der abhaus macht mal fenster zu die idee finde ich aber gut unten zeigt er mir
entsprechend an die garagen ob sie gerade noch offen oder zu ist ich kann eben das finde ich
nice sehr sehr nice in der garage ist ich meine das garage nur habe ich nicht bei mir was
dann das hoftor und das wird aus dem auto rausgesteuert dann eingebaut finde ich finde
ich sinnvolle sinnvolle idee ich habe mir ja danke matthias also ich finde es gut ich mag
diese kleinen schalter mit dem display so als unauffälliges dashboard das gleichzeitig
informationen anbietet und dir die möglichkeit erlaubt auch sachen zu steuern gut die fenster
wirst du jetzt nicht per knopfdruck zumachen können aber die garage im zweifelsfall was haben
wir als nächstes eine visuelle klingel rgb beleuchtung eine home automation gesendet jedenfalls
heißt das video so offenbar geht es um wohnungstür oder klingelanlage oder schlüsselbrett schauen wir
mal ich muss dazu sagen ich bin träger und genieße die freiheit man nicht zu hören und was was ich
habe das wort nicht verstanden was ist ich muss dazu sagen ich bin hörgeräte ich habe es überhaupt
nicht verstanden gerade hörgerät und genieße die freiheit man nicht zu hören und bei ärger
einfach die hörgeräte ausschalten zu können nachteil ist ich bekomme auch nicht mit wenn
jemand an der tür klingelt in dem moment deswegen habe ich diese tsc tür klingel an oder
gegensprich anlage ein bisschen verändert und würde die jetzt einfach mal aufmachen um zu
zeigen was genau dort verändern ist hier sieht man jetzt ist das eine siedleranlage sieht ein
bisschen aus wie meine was hat er den hersteller gesagt deswegen habe ich diese tss ne das ist
keine siedler das ist ja das was anderes sieht aber bei mir genauso aus ich glaube die dinger
sehen alle mehr oder weniger gleich aus um zu zeigen was genau der höher sieht auch exakt so
aus wie bei mir das gerät ein bisschen anders alles der gleiche shit wahrscheinlich ich habe
hier ein tsc reley eingebaut was bei tür klingeln das signal abfängt das reley schließt und
dieses signal weiter an den ungebauten akara türkommandat ist eine mietwohnung wobei was der
vermieter nicht weiß das finde ich gut dass der hersteller sowas hat sowas gibt es nämlich für
meine tür gegen sprechanlage nicht deswegen habe ich das selbst gebaut ich habe unten im keller
jrn raspberry pi stehen und der hat einen automation fett dran hier nicht der große ding den kleinen
den kleinen habe ich den da ja so ein ding hat er unten dran der respirator super high res
high res image gibt das vielleicht auch noch irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen bisschen bessere auflösung
ja so ein ding habe ich da unten dran und zwar das macht folgendes am raspberry pi das hat
einen input es hat genau es hat drei analog digital konverter inputs die bis zu 24 volt gehen und da
habe ich quasi einmal abgezweigt abgezweigt von dem den zwei treten für die tür gegen sprechanlage
weil es ist so wenn es klingelt an meiner tür dann also ruhe spannung es geht glaube ich sogar
bis bis bis ein bisschen mehr die ruhe spannung auf der leitung sind irgendwie aus dem kopf gar
nicht hin 24 volt wenn es klingelt geht das runter auf 22 volt wenn einer das gespräch
annimmt geht es runter auf 15 volt und dann wieder hoch auf 24 das heißt ich lese einfach
über den analog digital konverter ein welche spannung gerade auf dem diesem bus von der tür
gegen sprecher alles erkennt bus auf diesem signal auf diesem signal schaltung von der tür
gegen sprechanlage ist und anhand dessen kann ich dann erkennen ob es geklingelt hat oder nicht
weil es so was offizielles halt nicht gibt für meine tür gegen sprechanlage ja und nebenbei
ist dieses ding tatsächlich ganz praktisch du hast noch ein relay mit dem du schalten kannst
sachen und noch ein paar inputs zum kurs ist ist ist praktisch also wenn man einen raspberry
pi hat ist dieses wirklich ist eine gute zusammenstellung an komponenten kann man
empfehlen das ist natürlich keine anstiftung zur beschädigung von fremdeigentum schon mal weiter
dort ist das magnet stäbchen ausgebaut und plus und minus angelötet worden und gibt dann
dementsprechend die meldung an die homekit steuerzentrale weiter das ganze wenn ich
jetzt einmal dem was ich da schon ein bisschen blöd finde ist dass das ding überhaupt eine
knopfzelle braucht man könnte das nämlich garantiert irgendwie hier drüber mit einem
spannungswandler versorgen warum braucht das ding eine knopfzelle weil wenn der strom ausfällt
geht die ganze klingel nicht mehr da brauche das teil auch nicht
so sieht das ganze denn wieder zusammengebaut aus und dann werde ich das mal zeigen das ist
der akara sensor ja aber den das hätte ich geguckt ob ich das nicht auch irgendwie über
die über die spanung von der von der anlage versorgt kriege blim blim
für mich als höhlgeschädigte personen ein sehr sehr nette kann ich mir vorstellen das
bringt wirklich was ein bisschen austoben und ich bekomme ein optisches signal wenn es an der
tür geklingelt hat zusätzlich zu dem optischen signal bekomme ich noch eine mitteilung von
homekit in der es eben heißt die kugel wurde geschlossen und geöffnet was die tür klingel
wurde geöffnet also naja das ist wahrscheinlich homekit weil das als switch hinterlegt ist
anstatt einfach als backen geschlossen und geöffnet und somit weiß ich das geklingelt hat
hier sehen wir dann auch noch mal zu guter letzt die kurzbefehl kette fünf mal wiederholen
drei geräte sprich schuhschrank und die decken bären an eine sekunde warten alle lichter wieder
aus wieder eine sekunde warten und das ganze passiert fünf mal ich bekomme also zusammenfassend
obwohl meine geräte meine höhrgeräte aus sind mit dass es an der tür geklingelt hat durch die
mitteilung von homekit und durch das blinken der lichter cool zu sehen und wie das so ist mit
körperlichen einschränkungen das ist ja immer eine sache die sehr viel mehr menschen betrifft als
man so auf den ersten blick denkt zwar ist nicht jeder hörgeschädigt oder trägt ein hörgerät
aber viele menschen sind es ja zum beispiel auch temporär ich habe mir das so was früher immer
gewünscht um bei lauter musik oder ja kennt man aus call of duty wenn die granate neben einem
explodiert dann piepst für drei sekunden mit kopfhörern zu sehen wenn es klingelt also das
kommt sicherlich für viel mehr menschen in frage auch oder der heli abstürzt vielen dank auf
jeden der kenne ich ein video geschickt das heißt pillen automation has ich denke dass es ja die
abkürzung mit home assistant und has finde ich auch sehr unglücklich jetzt nicht total aggressiv
in diesem video sein wird aber wir schauen mal rein heute möchte ich euch zeigen wie home assistant
meine freundin und mir bei der familienplanung hilft hintergrund ist der dass meine freundin
täglich die pille nimmt und wir natürlich nicht wollen dass sie das ausgesehen vergisst aus diesem
grund erhält sie jeden abend eine erinnerung hat er gewisse eigenes interesse dran ja die pille
nehmen soll wenn pillen noch die pillen notifikation kann der vorschlag das tracking über home
assistant abzubilden auch schon ausreichende verhütung sein aber schön wenn es für euch
funktioniert noch schöner werden es finden solche automationen auch von frauen eingesendet werden
oder irgendwelche automationen also ein kleiner aufruf an die wenigen weiblichen zuschauerinnen
dieses kanals mal diese würstchenpartie hier ein bisschen aufzumischen die pille genommen hat
klickt sie auf die notification und den home assistant wird ein wirtswärterschalter umgelegt
außerdem wird die anzahl der genommenen pillen um viel hat er aber nicht rennen seinem home assistant
oder dies benötigt man um die notification beziehungsweise die automation innerhalb der
pillenpause abschalten zu können allerdings kann es auch mal passieren dass sie vergisst die pille
zu nehmen und die notification nicht anklickt wenn das der fall ist leuchtet der lightstrip unter
den pass auf dann gehen sie ins bett und der bett sensor erkennt sie sind im bett und dann sagt
hat achtung achtung pille nicht genommen leute in unserem schlafzimmer rot auf tatsächlich aber
jetzt fehlt bloß noch der gewicht sensor jetzt wird bloß noch der gewicht sensor wenn wir wie
immer vor dem schlafen gehen diese knopf drücken das ist feifett alter alle lichter in der wohnung
alarm alarm gut in diesem fall ist rotes licht im schlafzimmer so nach dem motto jetzt geht
nichts zu tun was andere menschen machen wenn sie im schlafzimmer rotes licht machen oder so was
auch immer für euch funktioniert habe ich für die umsetzung in home assistant dafür zwei entitäten
angedeckt ein virtueller schalter der registriert ob die pille genommen wurde und ein zähler der
mit zählt wie viele pille genommen wurden beziehungsweise welcher takt des cyklus momentan
ist die logik und home assistant besteht aus mehreren teilen der erste ist die automation die die
notification auf dem handy meiner freundin auslöst dass sie das doch so machen wie ravel diese läuft
jeden abend um 22 uhr und prüft zuerst ob der zähler größer 21 ist falls der zähler das ist
noch die home assistant variante ohne grafischen grafischen editor das schon ein paar bis schon
ein bisschen her oder 16 juni 21 ist wird die notification an das handy meiner freundin gesendet
die anderen teile habe ich im home assistant add-on note red umgesetzt die video beschreibung heißt
sogar verhütung mit home assistant und ich glaube hier verhüten tatsächlich viele mit home assistant
in dem wir eher abends unsere weiß nicht bewässerung steuerung fein justieren man muss halt prioritäten
setzen als rotes licht im schlafzimmer so sebastian zeigt uns wie er seinen smarten staubsauger noch
smarter gemacht hat ich bin sehr gespannt leute wie ich die gerne fahrrad fahren und leider keinen
platz draußen haben fürs bei kennen das problem und zwar wenn das bike mit in die wohnung nimmt
dann nimmt man auch zwangsläufig viel dreck mit rein kann ich mir vorstellen ich kenne das problem
nicht aber ich kann es mir vorstellen und zwar da ich meine touren immer über die app kommut
schräcke die vielleicht die leute kennen könnten die verwende ich auch zum wandern sobald ich hier
eine toure getrackt habe dass ich fahrrad gefahren bin und sobald ich dann wieder mein zu hause
verlasse merkt dass die steuerung die über den au broker realisiert ist und startet den robo rock
und das können wir testen ich beende die aufnahme jetzt sehen wir hier schon dass eine neue toure
getrackt wurde realisiert über ein skript nach au broker aus oder alles richtige pfeifert leute
wieder heute da er das erkannt hat löse ich mal aus dass ich gegangen bin das geht über den
au broker ping adapter einfach ich gehe jetzt einfach mal aus meinem wlan raus und dann müsste
gleich der robo rock starten könnte ein paar sekunden dauern wie wir sehen hat super funktioniert
und der ganze fahrrad dreck würde jetzt weg gesaugt werden das ist pfeifert es wird nicht
dafür gesorgt dass weniger dreck mit reingebracht wird es wird dafür gesorgt dass der dreck
weggesaugt wird die touren die zu hause enden nicht irgendwo weiß ich nicht andere stile oder
irgendwo anders auf der anderen seite ist die fallhöhe auch begrenzt wenn du woanders fährst
vermutlich würdest du beim nächsten nach hause kommen das rad dabei haben und selbst wenn nicht
im zweifelsfall würde der sauger saugen wenn du die wohnung verlässt okay du hast gewonnen man
kann sich auch mit unnötig langen bedingungen bei der automatisierungs erstellung aufhalten
ist gut du bekommst einen abgenommen sticker für diese automation also bekommst nicht wirklich
ein sticker weil ich keine habe vielleicht sollte ich sticker saugroboter sind von markus der zwei
automationen geschickt die erste dreht sich auch um einen robot saugroboter schon mal rein
was ist das was ist das für eine ansage
gut ich nehme an der fette sind die küche rumbrumm spannend würde sein was in der
küche passiert hoffentlich kommt er an ganz kaum erwarten
der fährt wahrscheinlich einfach wieder zurück
selbstständig leeren geht erst mit der nächsten roborock variante sehr spannend gewesen okay das
ist ja tatsächlich kein hexenwerk den einfach zu einer bestimmten zeit an einen bestimmten punkt
der wohnung zu fahren es ist eine gute es ist eine gute idee es ist wirklich eine clevere idee
da hätte ich auch drauf kommen können mit meinem dass ich den nicht einfach im wohnzimmer immer
da unter dem tisch rausfüllen muss sondern wenn er voll ist dass der sich einfach zum mülleimer
fährt und da auf mich wartet von wo man den taubtank einfacher auslernen kann das ist eine ganz
gute idee und gleichzeitig ist eine to do liste wenn er da in der küche vor dem mülleimer rum
lungert dann weiß er auslernen den eben auszulehnen dann auf die docktaste zu schicken dann fährt er
wieder zurück das ist auf jeden fall billiger als das empty wash fill dock für den s7 pro und den
ja das zeug teuer allerdings auch ein bisschen weniger komfortabel weil der mop nicht noch
gewaschen wird aber sicherlich eine einfache idee die glaube ich schon ein paar nachahmer finden
wird jetzt schauen wir uns noch mal das zweite video von marcus an so das video heißt abwesenheits
schaltung über ein stationäres tablet i o broker haussteuerung und da schauen wir jetzt auch mal
ein flur floorplan so eine visualisierung finde ich ja auch immer noch ganz gut ein schönes 3d
modell des grund ich hatte das auch mal ich ich ich fand es nicht so praktisch wie es auf den
ersten blick aussieht und dann können alle im haus einigermaßen nachvollziehen was wo wie
geschaltet wird das ist gut das ist gut dafür habe ich dafür habe ich meinen dashboard auch
dass ich weiß ok ich habe vergessen fenster zuzumachen was hat er denn da stehen was ist
das moderne kunst oder ups das moderne kunst sieht aus wie dübel sieht aus wie dübel zusammengeklebt
wohnzimmerfenster erinnerung wenn man wenn man das zu macht wenn man das haus verlässt und das
macht doch nicht die musik so laut leute und dann igel sich das haus ein und schaltet alles aus in
seiner video beschreibung steht auch noch mal dass im zweifelsfall das auch passiert wenn sich der
letzte sprachansage finde ich wie gesagt ich mag ich bin kein voice assistant fern deswegen
ich sehe es einfach auf beim dashboard wenn es gelb ist es ist auf wenn es blau ist es zu
aus dem geofans geht muss dann natürlich die erinnerung dass irgendein fenster noch offen
ist ein bisschen sinnlos weil man dann schon weg ist außer du motorisierst deine fenster ein
weiterer lebensraum von mir und dann haben wir daniel der hat seine smart home zahnbürste geschickt
und ich bin sehr gespannt was das sieht die einfach aus wie eine relativ normale zahnbürste aber
lassen wir uns eines besseren belehren und die wichtige frage ist direkt wer ist jonas
ich möchte kurz mit zahnbürsten halter vorstellen der hier an der wand klebt der
funktioniert im grunde wie eine schaukel dahinten ist so ein sensor dran mit bluetooth und magnet
und wenn ich die zahnbürste darunter nehme als familienvater muss ich das kurz klarstellen
das sieht für mich eher nach einer wippe als nach einer schaukel aus unwichtiges detail gleich
dann übermittelt der sensor ein signal an mein smart home und dadurch wird dann in der ganzen
wohnung die heizung ausgeschaltet automatisch mit der zähne kurz mit der heizung an gemacht weil
das ist eben meine schlafen geh zahnbürste und in der ganzen wohnung wird das licht das ist
eine schlafen geh zahnbürste hast du noch eine aufstehen wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
er kann ja auch alternativ einfach checken wenn die zeit nach 20 uhr ist oder so wir haben alle
unsere schwächen schauen wir uns mal deine zahnbürsten schaukel weiter ausgeschaltet
beziehungsweise im schlafzimmer und im bad wird das licht nur gedimmt das sieht man auch gleich
damit sich die augen so ein bisschen entspannen können vor dem schlafen gehen und das sieht dann
folgendermaßen aus da hat sich das licht gedämmt und der sensor hat ausgelöst also ging relativ
schnell funktioniert sehr schön mit mehreren leuten würde das allerdings ein sehr komplizierter
3d zahnbürsten wippe mechanismus werden müssen oder es braucht jeder seine eigene was ihn glücklich
macht wenn du es auch getan hast dann wirft mir das bei zeug.hu zeigen in den virtuellen
briefe aber die idee finde ich könnte das sicherlich auch einfacher machen anstatt anhand der
zahnbürste festzumachen vielleicht an irgendeinem tür sensor im badezimmer irgendwas aber die idee
ist auf jeden fall cool weil halt selbst ausgedacht das ist mal was ich brauche ja nachschub damit
ich immer zusammen was ausgefallen es gibt auch 50 euro für jeden dessen einsendung im video
vorkommt alles klar und für alle anderen schreibt gerne was nicht alles gibt zahnbürsten wippe
einfach 7d wippe easy was was macht aporet wieder
wer ist denn der magier mit maske
naja leute ich gehe jetzt mittagessen ich habe hunger af ich bin vier stunden online
gewesen viel länger als geplant vielleicht machen wir mittag weiter mit den github actions
alles klar wir sehen uns leute bis denn macht's gut zu